Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prett Love und ich begrüße.
Gabe zweiundsiebzig von UKW und das ist, wie sollte es anders sein, eine Freitagsausgabe, ein Corona-Erinnerung, es ist immer noch Corona-Krise. Unser,
was zu erzählen gibt, sind wir äh dran, das bin ich, Tim und natürlich Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Wie lange machen wir die Sendung noch?
Tja, äh also schwierige Frage.
Ich hoffe nicht mehr so lange so mal gucken, dass du dann vielleicht Sendungen über andere Themen machen.
Ich glaube, Themen gibt's immer genug, aber.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich meine, ich hätte vor einem Jahr auch nicht äh geglaubt, dass wir irgendwie.
Über fünfzig Sendungen oder so.
Kurz davor glaube ich oder es ist heute die fuffzigste, muss das mal schauen. Mhm.
So um die fünfzig Sendungen machen würden und äh immer noch dabei sein.
Würden. Und ich sage mal, Motivation oder das Interesse steigt und fällt natürlich so ein bisschen mit der Inzidenz. Das heißt, ich gehe mal davon aus, je niedriger die Inzidenzen.
Äh wenn sie auch fallen äh werden umso ja äh weniger natürlich ausgeprägt äh sein wird, der Wunsch oder Drang sich zu informieren, um
ja äh bessere Entscheidungen zu treffen, sage ich mal
und deshalb, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht sollten wir irgendwie dann auch so eine Inzidenz äh uns überlegen, äh so sagen so ein inzidenzabhängigen Plan.
Wo wir die Maßnahmen.
Wo wir dann, wo wir dann die, die äh anti äh Corona äh Maßnahmen so, dass wir dann zum Beispiel erstmal anfangen vierzehntägig zu werden oder so oder
dann in den, ich sage mal, ähm nur wenn's was Interessantes gibt, äh äh Mord umschwenken, irgendwann.
Bei welcher Inzidenz haben wir denn letzte Mal ausgesetzt?
Guckt mal, wann wir überhaupt aufgesetzt haben.
Einstellig. Ich glaube, einstellig, also äh also äh wobei die gingen dann schon wieder bis bisschen höher auch, aber ich glaube.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall die siebenundvierzigste Ausgabe von unserem Dialog hier. Also die fünfzig haben wir noch nicht voll. Die die kriegen wir auch noch voll. Gar kein, gar kein Problem.
Das glaube ich auch auf jeden Fall. Hm.
Ich gucke mal. Also wir hatten im Ende Augen schon wieder gesendet.
Okay, erster Juli hatten wir quasi den Break bis, also wir hatten Juli, August, wesentlichen Pause. Und das wäre auch so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, dass wir so Juli, August einfach auch so eine ganz klassische Sommerpause machen können.
Vielleicht sogar äh schon möglicherweise davor, werden wir sehen, ähm also im Moment ja ähm,
ist jetzt keine Prognose, aber äh,
so bei bei momentanem Tempo äh deutschlandweit bis fünfzig Inziden sind's dreiunddreißig Tage.
Ja äh und bis hundert in zehn Tagen so ungefähr, wenn das so weitergeht, ob das so weitergeht, da reden wir dann gleich mal drüber, wenn wir uns konkre,
mit den Zahlen äh äh beschäftigt haben.
Genau. Das können wir ja dann eigentlich auch gleich mal machen. Die Zahlen äh der Woche.
Was mir leider den den Zugriff entzogen auf deine.
Auf auf deinen kleinen internen ähm Grafengenerator, deswegen bin ich jetzt selber gerade so ein bisschen gespannt, weil ich mich doch mehr mit dem Impfgeschehen beschäftigt habe diese Woche.
Wie sieht's denn aus? Was haben wir denn?
Also die.
Fallen jetzt so gut seit ja über zehn Tagen äh etwa äh geht es berg.
In Deutschland mit den Fallzahlen. Wir sind jetzt nach Publikationsdatum.
Bei,
hundertdreiunddreißig Fälle pro hunderttausend Einwohner in den letzten sieben Tagen. So und äh ja, also das sieht auch jetzt.
Nicht so aus, als wenn sich das jetzt gerade umkehren würde. Ähm und der R-Wert ist eigentlich auch.
Die ganze Zeit gesunken, eigentlich länger schon so, der ist eigentlich seit ja mit äh Mitte April äh ist der, ist der runtergegangen und wir sind jetzt so knapp bei äh ja bei null Komma
acht acht, null Komma acht, neun ungefähr,
und da sieht es aber so aus, als wenn das jetzt das Ende der Fahnenstange langsam wäre, so als wenn wir da nicht mehr,
weiter runtergehen. Und ja, das ist jetzt noch nicht so richtig ein sicherer Abstand äh zu eins nach oben.
Insofern.
Ja äh ist sind haltig steigende Zahlen auch nicht für äh völlig ausgeschlossen. Im Moment.
Macht dir so sicher, dass wir unter null Komma acht acht nicht runterkommen.
Ähm mir, also was heißt sicher, äh wenn man sich die bisherige historische Kurve,
anschaut, der der R Werte dann,
waren wir selten und immer nur für eher kurze Zeit,
unter null Komma neun, ja? Also das ist irgendwie normale, also war bisher kein nachhaltiges Regime, sage ich mal und.
Auch äh so in Ländern, jetzt wie in Israel oder so, wenn man geguckt hat, da ist der R-Wert jetzt auch nicht,
durch durchs Impfen äh so super in den Keller gefallen. Er ist halt unter eins geblieben, aber auch so,
ich sag mal in der null achter null neuner Region, ja? Also insofern.
Ja und wir haben natürlich im Moment eine ganze Menge, was gerade äh auf den R-Wert drückt.
Und äh ja, es sind halt schon den vielen Ländern und in vielen Kreisen gibt es Ausgangssperren, findet kaum Schulunterricht statt gerade.
Einzelhandel ist weitgehend geschlossen. Die Gastronomie ist geschlossen.
Es sind viele im Home Office ja keine Partys die Jugendlichen müssen irgendwie abends zu Hause bleiben können sich nicht mehr heimlich treffen zum,
was auch immer. Äh ja.
Und also da ist, da ist im Moment viel, was äh was halt auf den R-Wert drückt und so bis A von null Komma neun bis eins ist halt der Weg nicht so weit so. Das heißt, es hängt halt jetzt sehr viel davon ab.
Wie schnell jetzt äh wieder gelockert wird und,
politisch scheint aber die Stimmung, na ja noch da zu sein, das auch noch gewarnt wird. Also es ist meine, also die Politik,
jetzt gerade so ein bisschen vorsichtig äh zu sein und äh möchte nicht nochmal
das Ganze verlängern. Das ist irgendwie mein Gefühl, dass das also alle den Braten noch nicht so recht trauen im Moment, aber das kann natürlich ganz ganz schnell umschlagen
und ähm ja, je nachdem, wie unvorsichtig wir jetzt beim Öffnen sind, glaube ich, äh.
Können wir da nochmal 'ne Trendumkehr sehen, wobei in allen.
Die ich mir angeguckt habe, die halt durchgeimpft haben, ist es nicht dazu gekommen bisher.
So, also Israel oder UK hatten jetzt keinen.
Neuen oder so, aber die waren, glaube ich, auch durchaus äh ja.
Vorsichtig beruht bei Israel, das ist schwer einzuschätzen. Ich habe da keine keine genauen Zahlen, welche Maßnahmen, wo noch wie lange aufrecht äh äh gehalten äh wurden, aber.
Ja vom.
Zumindest haben wir, haben wir derzeit 'ne ganz brauchbare Beschleunigung des der Impfkampagne und von daher, wenn sich noch 'ne Weile so hält.
Erzählen wir nachher nochmal was zu dann könnte das das natürlich äh unterstützen, dass wir dass wir so auf unter eins ähm ja unter eins bleiben für den.
Ich find's ja ganz geil, wenn man irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen drunter gehen könnte, aber na ja, okay. Man ist schon mit so wenig zufrieden mittlerweile. Es ist wirklich ernüchternd.
Ja, also am Ende des Tages äh bin ich immer froh, also wenn die Zahlen fallen so und äh irgendwie unter null neun, da kann man halt äh schon mal ja.
Von Woche zu Woche zumindest Unterschiede sehen, ne?
Ja, da kann man zumindest, ich sage mal, sehen das irgendwie in ein, zwei Monaten, ist dann schon ein
ein Ende in in Sicht oder oder sind halt niedrige Inzidenzen in, in Sicht. Äh so, wenn's sich nicht, nicht ändert
also mit jedem Tag kommt man äh da ein Stück näher. Ähm genau.
Was ist jetzt so ein bisschen der Schlüssel zum Erfolg, ne? Also das würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, du hast ja sicherlich jetzt auch nochmal die Altersgruppen angeschaut.
Ja, genau, gehen wir nochmal, also ähm interessant ist, dass in allen Altersgruppen äh jetzt die Inzidenz zurückgegangen ist, dass äh gut.
Ist jetzt nicht selten, dass in allen Altersgruppen, die Inzidenz äh zurückgeht, aber,
ähm ja äh ist einfach äh so und am stärksten ist sie halt zurückgegangen bei den Fünf- bis Vierzehnjährigen und bei den fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig Jährigen, also lagen bei den äh,
bei den Jüngeren und bei den sagen Familien im im Prinzip,
wahrscheinlich, also entweder äh quasi Kinder, die in der Familie leben oder äh halt bis fünfunddreißig äh sage ich mal durchaus auch äh gut, auch viele Eltern.
Darüber, aber äh ja, gibt's halt äh auch dann eine ganze Menge an äh jungen Eltern schon in der Klasse oder.
In der Altersgruppe.
Früher hieß das mal Eltern, heute heißt es junge Eltern.
Junge Eltern, genau.
Ich erinnere mich in der Grundschule wurden wir gefragt so wie alt unsere Eltern sind und
dann wurde daraus sagen, dass das Durchschnittsalter der einer Generation berechnet und damals, also das muss
dann so neunzehnhundertsiebzig gewesen sein, ähm kam bei uns in der Klasse um irgendwas mit zwanzig.
Jahren draus. Also irgendwo zwischen zwanzig und dreißig jedenfalls bewegte sich das aber näher bei der zwanzig noch als bei der Dreißig,
erinnern, ja. Äh gut jedenfalls.
Also das ist jetzt auch keine Errungenschaft der letzten Woche, sondern das geht ja jetzt seit zwei, drei Wochen so, ne. Der Trend.
Ja. Ja. Kann man, kann man sagen, also Höhepunkt war dann so am war dann Ende April bei den bei den fünf bis vierzehn Jährigen. Ähm ja.
So und genau und die sind jetzt beide eben unter zweihundert, also dort die die Inzidenzen,
hundertneunundachtzig bei den, sage mal, Schülern fünf bis vierzehn und,
hundertvierundachtzig bei den fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig jährigen und alle anderen liegen drunter und bei achtzig Plus äh sind wir jetzt bei zweiundfünfzig angekommen. Ähm.
Pro hunderttausend pro sieben Tage und.
Interessant ist aber gut, das kann jetzt Zufall sein, äh wenn man sich jetzt die pseudo R Werte nach Altersgruppen anguckt.
Dann liegen die grade alle total eng beieinander. Ähm also zwischen null Komma.
Acht, acht und null Komma neun. Ja, also null Komma null zwei ähm dazwischen, das,
nicht oft vor oder habe ich so noch gar nicht gesehen im im Grafen, dass dass die,
irgendwie so eng beieinander sind. Aber wie gesagt, kann jetzt einfach Zufall sein, aber äh ja, das deutet zumindest gerade darauf hin, äh dass in.
Allen Altersgruppen sich die Infektion gleich schnell äh ausbreitet oder beziehungsweise zurückgeht.
Zumindest kann man in keiner Altersgruppe grade vorwerfen, Treiber, Treiber der Pandemie zu sein.
Ja, ja, ja.
Genau, aber es ist natürlich nach wie vor noch sehr unterschiedlich betroffen, aber was so die Veränderung angeht, wie gesagt, liegen sie alle zwischen null Komma acht, acht und äh null Komma neun null.
Und das äh ja, fand ich schon ziemlich abgefahren. Hm ja, bei den Bundesländern hm.
So gibt's weiter die,
hat sich aber nicht weiter aufgespreizt so, sondern die marschieren in allen Bundesländern marschieren eigentlich auch nach nach unten, aber,
so Schleswig-Holstein mit einer dreiundfünfzig.
Ja fast kann man sagen weit abgeschlagen unten so danach Hamburg mit zweiundneunzig und ganz oben liefern sich Sachsen und Thüringen weiter so ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen
im Moment zweihundertzehn Sachsen und zweihundertneun Thüringen. So. Ja. Ähm.
Daher nichts aufregendes äh bei,
bei den Bundesländern, wobei da die R-Werte weiter auseinander äh liegen, so Thüringen, Saarland, Sachsen.
Über null Komma neun drei, null Komma neun sechs und Sachsen-Anhalt gerade null Komma acht zwo, also,
da gibt's schon gerade gewisse Unterschiede, aber äh jetzt auch nicht keine dramatischen Unterschiede gerade. Also im Moment marschiert alles so alle Altersgruppen und,
die meisten Bundesländer so im Gleichtakt nach unten so könnte man's ungefähr ausdrücken.
Also mit der gleichen Tendenz leicht unterschiedlicher Geschwindigkeit, sagen wir es mal so, ja.
Leicht unter Spinner, leicht unterschiedlichen Geschwindigkeiten, also es gibt jetzt grade keine großen Überholmanöver oder Ausbremsmanöver, so würde ich also fahren, mehr oder weniger im Moment alle so Kolonne.
Und keine Geisterfahrer.
Ja, keine Geige, genau, also Geisterfahrer haben wir auch.
Geisterfahrer freie Zone ist Deutschland gerade.
Mhm. Ja und ähm dann vielleicht aber noch zu bemerken,
so bei den Todesfällen, die leider nur sehr leicht zurückgegangen sind, also die sind die verlaufen wie immer noch waagerecht, müssten aber eigentlich bald dann auch noch einen Knick nach unten machen, aber.
Da gibt's halt äh gerade doch die krassesten Unterschiede zwischen den äh Bundesländern.
Also viel größer als bei den Inzidenzen. So, also bei den Fallinzidenzen, weil während in Schleswig-Holstein, was auch da ganz, ganz unten.
Saarland auch ähm im Prinzip nur null Komma fünf äh.
P äh hunderttausend in den letzten sieben Tagen, also im Prinzip eine eine von zweihunderttausend Personen ist in den letzten sieben Tagen,
gestorben sind es halt in äh Thüringen, vier Komma acht, also fast äh,
ja, also achtmal äh so viel und auch in in Sachsen und in Sachsen-Anhalt ähm so mit drei Komma zwo acht.
Ist das halt schon deutlich höher und ja im Großen und Ganzen immer in Hessen ist auch ein bisschen höher, aber es ist die sind da erst kürzlich hochgesprungen, aber ansonsten,
kann man sagen, so ganz grob.
Wird im Osten.
Gestorben wird im Osten. Das äh ist äh äh.
Leider äh so äh wie es aussieht. Und ähm ja, warum.
Das so ist. Ich meine, viele Gründe, aber äh letztlich ist es die Inzidenz in der Altersgruppe achtzig plus. Die halt das Ganze ausmacht und äh ja.
Und dort, ich meine, es ist halt einfach eine direkte Folge auch des Inzidenzverlaufs. Eigentlich ganz einfach sagen, da wo sich mehr Leute angesteckt haben, sterben auch mehr.
Wie gesagt, aber vor allem auf achtzig plus äh gesehen oder gut und sechzig bis neunundsiebzig macht ungefähr nochmal ähm.
Ein Drittel äh äh aus, also dreißig Prozent ungefähr.
Was ist das denn für eine Zahl? Das sind so zweihundertfünfzig Leute pro Tag, ne?
Jetzt Deutschlandweit meinst du oder.
Ja, hatte ich jetzt eher deutschlandweit hatte ich jetzt gerade im Ohr.
Ja, das waren so die, ja, etwas über zwei äh hundert, das sind waren jetzt tausendsechshundert pro Woche, glaube ich, äh an mir vorne.
Ja, zweihundertdreißig ungefähr. Mhm.
Mhm. Fünfzehn, sechzig pro Woche.
Mal einen Blick auf Berlin werfen.
Ja, Berlin fand ich halt äh so ein bisschen interessant.
Weil ich da mal geguckt habe, wie äh sieht's denn da so mit dem Verhältnis von Fällen und Todesfällen aus.
Und da fiel mir auf, dass in Berlin hm.
Was die Todesfälle angeht eigentlich gar nicht so eine richtige dritte Welle gegeben hat, ja? Die ist da gar nicht gar nicht sichtbar. So, während im Bund.
Ähm so hat sich der Anstieg, also die, die dritte Welle, hat sich da auch in einem Anstieg der Todesfälle äh bemerkbar gemacht, der war aber.
Viel, viel kleiner als in der zweiten Welle. Also.
Insofern sieht man da schon äh ganz gut auch auf Bundes äh Ebene, die Wirkung der Impfungen. Was ich aber bemerkenswert fand, war, dass es offenbar nicht.
Allen Ländern irgendwie gleich gelaufen ist, dass es eben auch Länder gab, äh wo dann die dritte Welle trotz Impfungen zu mehr Toten geführt hat, weil ich weiß nicht, entweder.
Ja, die nicht die anders geimpft haben oder langsamer geimpft haben oder ich weiß es nicht. Aber äh grundsätzlich, ich habe mir dann noch andere Länder angeguckt und in den meisten Ländern war es so. Also wenn man sich die.
Die Kurve der Todesfälle anschaut, sieht man in den meisten Ländern, hm, keine äh dritte Welle bei den Toten.
Aber äh in Deutschland gesamt dann eben doch. Ähm ja. Das äh fand ich so ein bisschen,
so eine so ein interessantes Ergebnis und ansonsten äh ja, laufen Berlin und der Bund irgendwie ziemlich,
gleich auf sowas die Inzidenzentwicklung angeht.
Also mal in Berlin läuft jetzt ein bisschen besser äh so, aber grundsätzlich ja hm.
Berlin jetzt in im Mittelfeld äh kann man sagen und deswegen eben.
Auch nicht so weit vom Bundesschnitt entfernt. Hm,
was in Berlin allerdings auch anders ist als jetzt als jetzt beim ähm Bund ist, dass die Schüler noch deutlich äh also die die fünf bis vierzehnjährigen immer noch mit,
hundertfünfundneunziger Inzidenz ähm äh unterwegs sind. Das ist zwar.
Ähm liegt zwar auch im Bundesschnitt, aber dafür liegen halt die, die fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig Jährigen und alle anderen liegen halt schon deutlich drunter und vor allen Dingen.
Was erfreulich ist, achtzig Plus in Berlin liegt die Inzidenz nur noch bei zweiundzwanzig.
Ja und äh das äh lässt halt dann hoffentlich erwarten, dass bald nicht mehr so viele Leute oder eigentlich
ist der Tag, den wir uns alle erhoffen, so der erste Tag, wo niemand mehr äh wieder an Covid äh stirbt für eine Woche,
wo wir halt dann so eine sieben Tage Todesfallinzidenz von null haben, das wäre echt was, ja? Oder überhaupt.
Großbritannien ist da ja jetzt gerade angekommen an dem Punkt, ne? Die hatten jetzt mal so den ersten Tag komplett ohne Sterbefall.
Israel ja auch, werden wir auch äh mir erzählt, ja und wenn man ansonsten.
Aber auch sechzig bis Achtzigjährige äh wenn ich das hier richtig sehe, sind mit einer Inzidenz in Berlin von vierundfünfzig, fünfundfünfzig, ganz ganz gut dabei und vor allem also auch stark fallend. Also das ist äh,
Kann schon bald so bald sein. Ende des Monats vielleicht haben wir eine Chance, dass das Sterben langsam mal auf.
Gut aus. Das einzige, was vielleicht in Berlin äh so,
die äh null bis Vierjährigen eigentlich unter unter unter Fünfjährigen äh die scheinen sich so ein bisschen, also die gehen am wenigsten zurück oder eigentlich ja.
Also da, da ist der insgesamt der geringste Rückgang äh zu beobachten, äh während bei allen anderen der,
irgendwie eher solide aussieht, ist es da so ein bisschen, hm. Ja und äh das.
Kann dann natürlich das sind dann manchmal auch so Anzeichen so dass das von da aus dann wieder die Infektion dann durchstartet.
Aber äh hoffen wir's mal nicht. Hoffen wir's mal nicht. Ähm ja und.
Berlin, dann könnten wir nochmal auf die Testzahlen schauen.
Ja und die beliebten Testzahlen es gab oft Twitter auch so sage mal,
Fragen, Leuten,
ist das jetzt wirklich äh gehen die Zahlen jetzt wirklich zurück oder ist da irgendwie wird da gerade irgendwie gemorschelt oder so.
Ähm und äh ja, alle Zahlen, äh die uns vorliegen und.
Die Testzahlen bestätigen halt, dass wir es wirklich auch mit einem Rückgang jetzt der äh Infektion zu tun,
haben und die Testzahlen sehen so aus, die Tests sind weniger in der letzten.
Kalenderwoche in der in der siebzehnten.
Ähm die sind, ja, um fünf Komma sechs Prozent auf eins Komma drei drei Millionen zurückgegangen, also nicht viel.
Aber die Anzahl der positiven Tests ist um fünfzehn Prozent zurückgegangen und.
Das macht halt dann 'nen Rückgang der positiven.
Halt von zwölf Komma vier drei auf elf Komma zwei.
Prozent ähm ja und das ist ein Rückgang von neun Komma neun Prozent, also äh passt halt auch alles zusammen und mit anderen Worten.
Ja, Rückgang der positiven Quote bedeutet in der Regel auch Rückgang der Dunkelziffer und ist eigentlich immer ein ganz guter Beleg dafür, dass äh ja.
Zahlen wirklich, also die Infektion wirklich runter äh gehen und das nicht irgendwie durch jetzt, keine Ahnung, Knappheit an Tests oder äh irgendwie sowas äh verursacht ist oder Unlust.
Sich testen zu lassen.
Ja, das könnte jetzt wirklich so ein Signal sein, dass dass diese dritte Welle jetzt kein, keine weitere Fahrt mehr,
Wir hatten letzte Woche ja schon gesehen, aha, okay, positiven Quote, stabilisiert sich so ein bisschen, da wussten wir noch nicht so richtig, was damit ist und jetzt ist hier eigentlich das erste Mal
Wochenvergleich nennenswert gefallen, sodass man sagen kann, okay, das könnte jetzt ein Trend sein. Trotzdem muss man sehen.
Wir sind immer noch über dem Niveau der ersten Welle.
Und äh auch nicht zu knapp und das ist halt insgesamt einfach noch ein viel zu hoher Wert und der müsste jetzt die nächsten Wochen auch deutlich fallen.
Damit alle anderen Vermutungen, die wir hier so angestellt haben, sich auch wirklich bestätigen.
Ja? Immerhin ähm wir haben auch äh zur positiven Quote, um das zu sagen, wir haben,
weit und breit die höchste positiven Quote bei Tests, also ich
Ich kenne jetzt kein Land, also in der, in der ganzen Liste jetzt grade, im Moment eher so sämtliche Nachbarländer, aber auch äh ja, USA, UK oder wo wo du hin,
Baltikum ja? Niemand hat so 'ne hohe positiven Quote wie wir.
Außer Indien vielleicht. Auch nicht.
Nee. Ich glaube nicht, oder? Hatte ich jetzt nicht geguckt. Aber gut, Indien testet.
Indien warten doch, doch, doch, doch, Indien ging komplett durch die Decke, also.
Nee, Indien stimmt, Indien äh gut, Indien hat äh ja hat auch kaum Tests, also da wird halt auch kaum äh getestet, aber so ansonsten ist das halt äh mal heißt A.
Bei uns sind die Inzidenzen ja so viel niedriger, also hm.
Guckt man auf die positiven Quote äh ist bei uns einfach die dunkelste Fahrt höher als in den meisten Ländern. Das heißt, eigentlich muss man.
Sagen beim Vergleich von Inzidenzen mit Deutschland muss man eigentlich bei den meisten Ländern irgendwie,
bei Deutschland ein bisschen was draufrechnen auf die Inzidenz.
Ja, also wirklich mit der Ausnahme äh Indien ist schon schon klar. Also Chile äh liegt ein bisschen unter.
Deutschland, war kurzfristig sogar noch höher, also da ist auch noch sehr, sehr wackelig, also klar, wenn man jetzt gräbt, wird man wahrscheinlich irgendwas finden, aber äh immer europäischen Vergleich auf jeden Fall und der ist ja nicht ganz unerheblich. Da äh sticht Deutschland doch schon,
sehr klar hervor.
Also wir haben eine Höhe positiven Quote, ja sogar also hinter uns jetzt die Reihenfolge ist dann Holland gerade Schweden, Polen.
Japan, Rumänien, Estland, Frankreich, Belgien, Schweiz, alle niedere, niedrigere positiven Quote, viel niedrigere, sogar auch Tschechien, irgendwie ist äh ganz weit unten gerade und.
Italien, Griechenland, äh wir haben alle eine niedrigere positiven Quote gerade. Was.
Eine Kombination eben aus natürlich weniger testen ist äh aber ähm ja auch dann letztlich einer höheren Inzidenz.
Bei einer höheren einer höheren Infektion als äh gemessen wird.
Könnte auf jeden Fall besser sein, um es mal abzuschließen.
Ja, ja, also, ja, so richtig auf die Schultern,
können wir uns nicht. Also wir sind jetzt auch was den Endspurt angeht. Also holen wir jetzt nicht auf im Endspurt, sagen wir es mal so. Es war jetzt ein Marathon und jetzt im Endspurt so äh ist nichts.
Wenn wir jetzt.
Nicht als Erste ins Ziel.
Nee, nee, also ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir hier jetzt irgendwie noch äh so die super Puste hätten grade im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern.
Noch mal ein Blick auf andere Länder äh werfen jetzt.
So als Abrundung des Zahlenblocks, weil ich glaube, du hast da noch was rausgesucht.
Ja, ich hatte.
Vor allen Dingen jetzt eben geguckt, äh so einmal immer ganz gerne kommunativ die.
Zahl der Toten pro eine Million, wie also wie viel wie groß der gestorbene Anteil der Bevölkerung ist durch Covid äh so nehme ich auch immer Graf der Schande. Ähm,
und äh ja.
Ist halt ganz oben in meiner Liste jetzt und die umfasst halt im Wesentlichen äh die ganzen Nachbarländer plus andere europäische Länder, plus USA und UK und,
asiatische Länder und Soja. Ähm.
Also Tschechien ist ist ganz, ganz weit oben mit, wo im Prinzip.
Ähm ja dreitausend von einer Million.
Also so null Komma drei Prozent der Bevölkerung sind gestorben.
Ja. Mhm. Ja. Und.
Da liegt Deutschland so ungefähr im im Mittelfeld, also im Jahr,
unterhalb der Mitte, auch und zwar unter dem europäischen äh Durchschnitt. Und,
was aber im wesentlichen daran liegt, dass wir in der ersten Welle.
Ziemlich gut gemeistert äh haben.
Und in der zweiten Welle, wo äh ja, haben wir halt und und in der dritten jetzt haben wir halt nichts gekonnt.
Und sind dadurch nur von Tschechien übertroffen worden, die in der ersten Welle noch viel, viel besser waren als wir und dafür dann in der zweiten Welle halt so richtig ab
gehoben sind und dann noch eine dritte und eine vierte hinterher gemacht haben und äh ja.
Gar nicht genug kriegen konnten. Sind so ein Covid-Wellenbad sozusagen.
Ja
Ansonsten ähm im Moment vielleicht noch äh Wert zu erwähnen, dass in dieser Liste auch Schweden im Moment so die höchste Inzidenz hat. Ähm.
Aktuell. Also ja, da also da gab's halt so die Länder,
die da dort
Wellen hatten, äh haben das alle in den Griff gekriegt, während bei Schweden einfach ähm ja die Inzidenzen eben weiter angestiegen sind und jetzt,
zwar auch zurückgehen äh zurückgegangen sind, aber eben teilweise deutlich langsamer als in,
in anderen äh Ländern, so dass äh die.
Auf jeden Fall äh auch deutlich deutlich gerade über dem europäischen Durchschnitt liegen und.
Eigentlich überall liegen, auch über USA und UK und Polen und Tschechien und haste nicht gesehen.
Es ist keine Moderegion. Das kann man jetzt nicht sagen.
Keine, keine Modellregion im Moment und äh ja. Es sterben dort zwar jetzt äh.
Nicht so viele Leute, wie man aufgrund der Insidenz äh jetzt.
Meinen äh würde aber äh wie gesagt insgesamt äh sind sind's haben sie halt auch äh gerade nicht nicht toll äh performt bisher in der Pandemie und ähm.
Dreihundertvierziger Inzidenzgrade, also das läuft da nicht so richtig geil.
Keine Ahnung. Also aus Schweden muss ich sagen, bin ich nicht schlau geworden, das äh finde ich auch so ein bisschen so eine kleine Enttäuschung.
Abgesehen von unseren lokalen Enttäuschungen. Gut, damit können wir vielleicht mal den Zahlenblock äh abschließen.
Oder vielleicht noch nicht so ganz. Ähm vielleicht sollten wir nochmal ganz kurz drauf eingehen. Ich glaube, viel müssen wir da nicht zu sagen. Es gab so einen kleinen Aufreger diese Woche,
dass äh ein paar Leute äh Sachen haben, oh mein Gott, hier äh RKI ändert seine Berechnungsmethode und jetzt wollen wir uns irgendwie hier alle ähm jetzt wollen sie uns hier irgendwie alle hinters Licht führen.
Letztlich, was hier beobachtet wurde, war mehr oder weniger die äh die Vereinheitlichung der,
Methode für was ist denn jetzt eigentlich gerade die Inzidenz? Weil nach
dem Aktivwerden der Bundesnotbremse hatten wir ja eigentlich das erste Mal diesen Fall, dass tatsächlich mal bundesweit einheitliche Regeln galten. Das erste Mal in dieser ganzen Pandemie und nicht jeder irgendwie sein eigenes Süppchen,
konnte oder zumindest nur noch in sehr eingeschränkten Maße,
und naja, wenn man halt einheitliche Regeln haben will, dann braucht man natürlich auch einheitliche Messmethoden und Bewertungsmethoden und dann wurde sich eben geeinigt auf, na ja, die vom RKI veröffentlichten Meldezahl.
Und wie wir ja hier schon nie müde geworden sind, zu diskutieren und heraufzuzeigen, sind ja diese Meldezahlen insofern immer etwas schwierig, als dass sie eben prinzipiell so wie das RKI das eben handhabt,
immer niedriger sind als sie letztlich sich nach ein paar Tagen Korrektur und Nachmeldung herausstellen.
Der Tageswert, der ihr auch immer rumgereicht wird und der immer in den Zeitschriften steht, gilt im Prinzip ein paar Tage später schon nicht mehr und nähert sich, wie wir gesehen haben, eigentlich diesem Publikationsmittel an.
Was wir immer genommen haben. Das heißt, nach einer Woche stimmt eigentlich die Zahl, die wir immer genommen haben, nur tagesaktuell ist sie halt einfach,
niedriger. So, aber da ja jetzt hier Regeln galten mit
wenn so und so viele Tage, die sie in nie äh unter oder über hundert ist oder was auch immer, so musste dieser Wert ja dann eben auch dauerhaft gelten und der wurde dann nicht korrigiert, sondern man halt immer diesen zu niedrigen.
Und da haben sich halt viele drüber aufgeregt. Wir können halt, glaube ich, eigentlich nur zu sagen, so ja, haben wir erstens schon immer gesagt und zweitens ist es irgendwo auch,
egal.
Weil auch dieser Messwert von hundert oder hundertfünfzig oder hundert hundertfünfundsechzig oder so, der ist ja auch irgendwie aus den Haaren gezogen,
der repräsentiert nichts. Das ist nichts anderes als ein politischer Kompromiss. Und wenn man ohnehin schon an so einem,
politischen Kompromisszahl entlang Entscheidungen fällt, dann ist es eigentlich auch egal, wie richtig,
dieser Messwert ist, weil Hauptsache, der bleibt dann irgendwie gleich und dann tariert sich das mehr oder weniger eh wieder alles aus.
Mhm. Und letztlich kam's, also ich glaube, wie es wie es zu der Kontroverse jetzt kam, war.
Dass äh sagen jetzt ja auch definiert werden musste, äh wenn bestimmte Werte an so und so viel aufeinanderfolgenden Tagen über oder unterschritten äh äh werden oder,
dann.
Passiert irgendwas oder nicht mehr.
Genau, kann irgendwie gelockert werden oder muss verschärft werden oder so. So und.
Jetzt sind halt wahrscheinlich einige findige Leute auf die Idee gekommen, äh dann,
nicht die an dem Tag vermeldete Inzidenz zu nehmen, ähm sondern,
dann, ich sage mal, am dritten Tag,
Inzidenz für die letzten beiden Tage, um die äh noch neu eingegangenen Meldungen quasi zu erhöhen.
Ja, und dann zu sagen, Moment mal, aber ähm die Inzidenz ist ja nicht erst jetzt seit zwei Tagen überschritten, sondern schon jetzt seit drei Tagen mit den ganzen Nachmeldungen und so. Ja und.
Das macht natürlich jetzt dann
noch weniger Sinn, ja? Also äh das das so zu handhaben, also das wäre dann äh endgültig die die Krücke und,
viele Leute irgendwie faul äh gerufen, aber ja, es ist nicht schlechter oder nicht besser äh als äh vorher und
am Ende
ob und wie schnell die Zahlen sinken und da spielt es jetzt nicht so wirklich die Rolle,
ähm und.
Was ich halt mache und man kann halt sehr schön nachgucken, wie man auf Risikotabelle DE äh habe ich halt beide Berechnungen,
da kann man sich dann eine von aussuchen
und äh die Trendberechnung für beide stimmt auch, weil um den Trend zu berechnen, nehme ich dann sagen den Meldestand von vor sieben Tagen
und vergleiche den mit dem aktuellen Meldestand, sodass sozusagen äh in.
Beiden äh sagen, gleich viele Fälle fehlen, ja. Wenn man jetzt einfach immer nur nimmt,
sagen, die aktuelle, den aktuellen Dampf und dann dort gucken würde, aha
sagen, nach Meldedatum so und so viele Fälle in den letzten sieben Tagen und so und so viel Fälle in den sieben Tagen davor, dann würde man immer nur sinkende Zahlen
sehen, weil halt die aus den letzten sieben Tagen noch deutlich unvollständiger sind, aber,
Deswegen ja, nehme ich halt quasi den Dampf von vor sieben Tagen und gucke äh und berechne die Zahl auf dem damaligen Wissensstand und vergleiche den dann mit dem mit dem Neuen und ja,
Kann man halt äh eben nachgucken und man sieht halt äh dass meistens äh nach Meldedatum.
Die Zahlen niedriger ist, aber nicht immer, das hängt eben auch so ein bisschen ab, ob die Zahlen gerade auch steigen oder fallen und es kann auch, also die Inzidenz kann, äh wenn äh wenn,
Zahlen jetzt schnell nach oben gehen kann, auch äh diese Methode mit dem äh,
RKI nach Meldedatum, so die kann dann auch schon mal höhere Zahlen ergeben.
Gut. Dann äh muss man jetzt glaube ich erstmal so ganz allgemein als Zwischenfazit mal fragen.
So ist die dritte Welle, die jetzt eigentlich gebrochen? Wird es eine vierte Welle geben oder.
Ist das jetzt schon sind wir jetzt sozusagen, sehen wir grade den Anfang vom Ende.
Ja, ich hoffe, Letzteres.
Wie ich vorhin schon äh gesagt habe, mit einem R-Wert von null Komma neun,
nicht so viel Abstand äh bis bis zur Eins und ähm im Prinzip.
Kann, ich sage mal, na so ungefähr rechnen jede Lockerung, die wir machen, äh so also größere Lockerung,
kann so ungefähr null Komma eins äh auf den R-Wert obendrauf geben. Auf der anderen Seite durch die Impfungen, durch die zunehmenden, ich habe das jetzt noch nicht,
noch nicht wirklich umgerechnet, äh müsste ich vielleicht mal machen, äh wie viel,
R Wertdämpfung so pro Woche im Moment dazu kommt, aber.
Es äh dürften jetzt nicht, also es ist jetzt nicht gewaltig, ja? Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da pro Woche irgendwie jetzt eher um null Komma eins äh runtergehen würde durch die,
die Impfungen grade, sondern da sind wir jetzt, glaube ich, so in dem, im, im Gleichgewicht langsam angekommen.
Und jetzt ist es ein Wettrennen äh zwischen eigentlich Impfungen.
Und Sommer auf der einen Seite und äh Lockerungen auf der anderen Seite.
So und
ja im Moment gewinnen halt Sommer und Impfungen und Maßnahmen ja also zusammen so
die Dinge, aber sie liegen jetzt gerade vorne oder laufen schneller.
Aber mit ja, wie gesagt, jeder Lockerung so können wir damit rechnen, eigentlich.
Dass der R-Wert steigt.
Beziehungsweise Petida und Lockerungsdiskussionen, wie wir ja gemerkt haben.
Mhm. Mhm. Genau und mit jedem mit jeder Impfterminvergabe äh erstmal möglicherweise sinkt.
Ja, haben wir auch noch einen Update zu, glaube ich. Äh,
Um jetzt irgendeine Vorhersage zu machen, müsste man jetzt das Mindset von Politik,
Bevölkerung äh so ein bisschen vorhersagen, wie sich das ändern wird mit fallenden Zahlen und ähm ja.
Also noch haben wir glaub ich den Wendepunkt noch nicht erreicht, das ist so so mein Gefühl
aber so langsam, also ich ich glaube, es wird in den nächsten Wochen dann äh so, ja, wenn die sagen, Lockerungstermine hageln, das ist ja nicht, nicht, nicht wirklich möglich
aber äh wir werden ähm, ich meine, es ist wir haben jetzt.
Sechs Bundesländer, die offiziell unter hundert sind
in der, in der Inzidenz und Berlin gehört dazu, jedenfalls nach Meldedatum nach Publikationsdatum, wer Berlin noch bei hundertsechs, aber nach RKI-Messungen sind wir schon bei achtundneunzig Komma sechs, so. Das heißt, wir werden halt jetzt,
zunehmend bei,
Unterschreitungen von hundert werden halt Maßnahmen wegfallen und bei Unterschreitungen von fünfzig, also in Schleswig-Holstein müsste.
Dass jetzt.
In den nächsten Tagen, also in der nächsten, innerhalb der nächsten Woche, eigentlich so in äh zwei, drei, vier Tagen äh müsste Schleswig-Holstein dann offiziell unter fünfzig.
Fallen ähm.
Ja und dann geht es auch langsam so mit der äh Urlaubssaison auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise los. Das,
Wetter wird in dem Maße eine große Rolle spielen, sozusagen was die Entscheidung für Lockerungen betrifft. Also ist noch ein bisschen offen, aber ähm,
Es gibt zumindest anders zur Hoffnung, dass wir also ich denke, was sicher ist, es ist.
So eine richtige Verschärfung der Situation steht grade nicht an. Die Frage ist nur, wie schnell wird's besser.
Dass es eben auch so spürbar besser wird, dass wir wirklich den Anfang vom Ende sehen, so das glaube ich, ist so der Punkt, an dem wir jetzt gerade sind.
Ja, also wenn dann erwarte ich.
'ne gewisse Stagnation vielleicht noch oder im Worst Case sozusagen nochmal 'nen Aufbäumen.
Ähm so. Das könnte uns, das kann man im Moment nicht ausschließen, hoffen wir's nicht.
Aber ähm ja, im Moment gibt es gibt es auch keine keine Anzeichen dafür. Könnte auch sein, dass es in einzelnen Bundesländern vielleicht passiert, also Thüringen ist halt so ein so ein Wackelkandidat, sage ich mal, mit auch.
Äh von null Komma neun vier, der äh deutlich über den anderen Ländern äh liegt.
Ja Schleswig-Holstein glaube ich so auf der anderen Seite.
Brauchen sich jetzt keine großen Sorgen zu machen und.
Also wenn jemand sozusagen, hm, als erstes raus ist in Deutschland, dann Schleswig-Holstein,
kann man glaube ich schon mal festhalten. Der Vorsprung ist äh signifikant. Gut, lass uns nicht weiter äh im Kaffeesatz lesen,
ein paar Studien angucken und wo wir jetzt, bevor wir zu den Impfzahlen äh kommen, wollte ich nochmal kurz äh den ganzen Infektionsbereich,
schließen,
jetzt eine Studienveröffentlichung aus Tirschenreuth, äh immerhin einer, der am heftigsten betroffenen Landkreise in Deutschland und auch hier öfter mal erwähnt worden, deswegen.
Da gab's jetzt eine Antikörperstudie, die veröffentlicht wurde aus einer Untersuchung noch aus dem letzten Jahr bis Juni zwanzig zwanzig, also quasi alles erste Welle
Da geht's nochmal um diese Frage mit Dunkelziffer und so weiter. Wir erinnern uns ja, wir hatten ja dann äh früh diese ganze Gangelt-Studie und,
berg und ich war äh Hendrik Streck und diese ganze Aufregung äh darum, das vergessen wir jetzt mal. Schauen wir uns mal an, was diese Studie sagt.
Hier wurden also äh Leute ab vierzehn Jahre untersucht und äh einen Antigenen äh also einen Antikörpertest gemacht.
Auf, wie ich vermute, halt so Nukleotit Protein äh Antikörper, also.
Man halt genau schaut, dass äh das jetzt eine reine Infektion war und ja, stellt sich raus, acht Komma sechs Prozent der Bevölkerung wiesen solche Antikörper auf.
Das ist schon mal ganz ordentlich, ne? Also acht Komma sechs Prozent des gesamten Landkreises bis Juni zwanzig, also in der ersten Welle.
Zum Vergleich, wenn ich das jetzt äh richtig in Erinnerung habe, da in der Tabelle kann man gerade entnehmen, dass äh innen bis heute wir eine gemeldete Infektionsrate haben von ungefähr acht Prozent der Bevölkerung.
Hier also schon vor einem dreiviertel Jahr acht Komma sechs Prozent und,
überrascht, insofern nicht als, dass wir ja schon immer wussten, Dunkelziffer gibt's, nur diese Dunkelziffer war halt immer sehr schwierig zu bewerten.
Die ähm Verteilung ist wohl auch über alle Altersgruppen hinweg ähm gleich äh gewesen. Ähm.
Bei äh den Personen mit Infektion bis zwanzig zwanzig, also bei denen man's wusste,
hatten wohl irgendwie vierundneunzig Prozent dieser Antikörpertests. Also man hat sozusagen,
relativ scharfkantiges Schwert hier gewählt für diese Messmethode. Also man wusste einfach, okay, ihr seid halt auch äh,
bestätigte Infektionen, ihr habt da mal so einen Test gemacht und da konnten dann sozusagen auch bei vierundneunzig Prozent Antikörper direkt,
nachgewiesen werden. Also es wurden wohl so drei Tests gemacht oder so oder mehrere Tests gemacht und dann hat mindestens einer angeschlagen,
Ähm jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie verteilt sich ähm das? Und.
Verhältnis von den Leuten, die halt Antikörper positiv waren.
Bei den Leuten, die damals noch nicht als infiziert gehalten, also die eigentliche Dunkelziffer, die lag bei vier zu eins.
Ähm.
Also so eine Dunkelziffer von von Faktor fünf, das heißt so viel wie achtzig Prozent aller Infektionen äh wurden damals einfach durch die Teststrategie nicht erfasst.
Das variiert jetzt natürlich nach Alter bei der Gruppe der Vierzehn bis Zwanzigjährigen,
war der Faktor bei zwölf, also zweiundneunzig Prozent der Infizierten
Infektion wurde dort nicht erkannt oder nicht gemessen. Und bei zunehmenden Alter nimmt das irgendwie ab und bei den über fünfundachtzig Jährigen ähm war es immerhin noch eins Komma sieben.
Ja, das ist äh sagen schon sind im Prinzip die Größenordnung mit den vier Jahren eigentlich auch immer kalkuliert haben.
Welche die Faktor zwölf oder die Faktor eins Komma sieben?
Nein, erstmal den den äh nee den Durchschnitt,
Faktor so ich glaub dort kam halt Dunkelziffer Faktor von fünf raus. Ich hatte in meiner Tabelle lange sechs Komma fünf benutzt.
Die Frage ist halt jetzt äh natürlich wie weit kann man jetzt Tischenreuth, wie weit ist das jetzt repräsentativ äh für.
Die gesamte Republik und ich würde erstmal sagen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, also da kann es Schwankungen geben und die also die Größenordnung von von fünf, muss ich sagen, bin ich eigentlich dann äh ganz zu zufrieden, das äh sagen die.
Schätzung mit äh ja äh sechs Komma fünf äh jetzt durchaus für die gesamte Republik jetzt nicht völlig außerhalb des äh.
Dessen lag, was hier mal gemessen wurde an der Stelle.
Das heißt, der ein berechnetes Risiko hatte auch äh Hand und Fuß.
Ja, also ja. War jetzt nicht, nicht völlig übertrieben äh so, aber auch nicht völlig äh ja, untertrieben. Und.
Ja, weißt du zufällig, wann bist du welchen Monat Juni? War das.
Juni zwanzig.
Juni zwanzig, ja im im Juni zwanzig lag halt ähm.
Fallinzidenz bei eins Komma sechs Prozent äh der Bevölkerung.
Und acht Komma sechs war lange das Ergebnis äh der deren Messung, ja.
Das heißt, Faktor fünf. Ja.
Die Zahlen waren schon immer fünfmal so hoch, die Frage ist, können wir jetzt die äh Infektionszahlen von Deutschland, die die äh kumulativen auch mal Faktor fünf nehmen und kriegen wir dann quasi so eine Einschätzung dafür, wie viele Infizierte schon rumlaufen?
Nee, eben, wie gesagt, äh also grob ja, es ich sage mal, äh also ähm.
Oder so rum. Wir wissen, dass danach äh die Dunkelziffer äh massiv zurückgegangen ist und,
die meisten Fälle äh sind auch bis Anfang Mai dort angefallen. Also wir hatten halt die anderthalb Prozent,
wurden,
ähm ja sogar Ende April schon überschritten. So, ja und in der Phase wissen wir aber, lief das halt noch mit den PCR-Tests erst an.
Und als dann aber äh die Inzidenzenhalt gefallen waren, also im Grunde genommen im äh Anfang Mai äh waren,
dort schon einstellig in also die waren dort bis fünfhundertachtzig ungefähr während der,
Pandemie, was in Wirklichkeit, wie wir jetzt wissen, zweitausendsechshundert äh wahrscheinlich,
gewesen ist äh so, also zweitausendsechshundert von hunderttausend äh haben sich da in einer Woche infiziert.
Äh zwei Komma sechs Prozent in einer Woche. Und deswegen ist im Prinzip seit Mai zwanzig zwanzig.
Ist die dunkelste Fahrt eigentlich schon äh.
Eher eine andere, also äh und ich habe aus jetzt anderen Zahlen im wesentlichen Normierung äh über die Sterbezahlen bin ich.
Auf einen Faktor von eins Komma fünf bis zwei äh gekommen vom.
Peak.
Erste Welle gegenüber Peak zweite Welle. Also ich sage mal eins Komma sieben fünf ungefähr wahrscheinlich könnte so ein realistischer Faktor sein, das heißt man müsste eigentlich.
Die damalige Fünfziger-Inzidenz den Peak.
Mal eins Komma sieben fünf nehmen ungefähr um äh das mit heutigen Inzidenzen zu vergleichen.
Was ist jetzt so deine Schätzung, wie welchen Faktor wir jetzt auf die gemeldeten Infektionszahlen in Deutschland drauf legen müssen, um irgendwie an so eine Realität äh uns ranzutasten?
Ähm.
So die globale Komplettpandemie, Dunkelziffer für Deutschland. Drei.
Drei. Ja. Ich glaube, drei ist ein.
Und was haben wir jetzt für eine Infektionssumme?
So in äh Deutschland.
Publikationen, Jahrhunderttausend haben wir äh viertausend irgendwas, also vier Komma vier Komma zwei Prozent.
Vier Komma zwei Prozent mal drei macht ungefähr zwölf Prozent. Also man kann wir können mal davon ausgehen, zwölf Prozent der Deutschen haben sich irgendwie mal Covid eingetreten.
Gut. Das bringt uns doch zu äh den anderen Zahlen, nämlich den Impfzahlen.
Denn wenn man jetzt mal diese äh zwölf Prozent im Sinne haben, dann müsste ja mehr oder weniger die Zahl der äh zuerst Geimpften jetzt ähm na ja, also
richtig addieren kann man's nicht, weil da wird sicherlich jetzt auch die eine oder andere Person dabei
gewesen sein, die sich schon mal infiziert hat, die jetzt auch noch geimpft wurde, aber einfach um das mal so ein bisschen im Sinn zu halten.
Wenn man sich jetzt mal die äh Impfkampagne anschaut, wie es jetzt so gelaufen ist, kann man sagen, es läuft ganz gut.
Ich habe jetzt mal die Methode der letzten zwei Wochen, die ich hier schon mal berichtet hatte, einfach beibehalten. Das heißt, ich hole mir nach wie vor die Daten vom Impfashbot, die da publiziert werden und ähm,
fummeln mich da so ein bisschen durch und finde auch nach wie vor diesen Faktor sieben Tage Schnitt bei den Impfungen,
ganz brauchbar. Wir sind also jetzt so in Phase vier der der Impfkampagne,
sich so ein bisschen dadurch manifestiert, dass die Zahlen so zwischen fünfhunderttausend und fünfhundertsiebzigtausend pro,
Tag im Sieben-Tage-Schnitt herum Mähand. Stand heute, sagen wir mal bei fünfhundertvierunddreißigtausend, achthundertfünfundsiebzig Erstimpfungen pro Tag,
Die Zahl ging so in den letzten sieben Tagen kontinuierlich nach unten und das hat im Wesentlichen damit zu tun, dass die Zahl der Zweitimpfungen ansteigt,
Also wir haben eigentlich insgesamt eine ganz gute Liefersituation. Das heißt, es ist eine ganze Menge Zeug da.
Aber dadurch, dass in zunehmenden Maße der Impfstoff eben jetzt für Zweitimpfung verwendet werden muss, um diese Kurve grade relativ stark ansteigt. Und jetzt ungefähr bei zwanzig Prozent der Impfungen sind, also von,
von zehn Impfungen sind halt einfach zwei Zweitimpfungen derzeit.
Und deswegen äh knickt halt die Zahl der der Erstimpfung ein bisschen ein. Ist aber halt trotzdem noch ein relativ hohen Niveau. Und das bedeutet, dass wir eben jetzt einunddreißig Komma fünf Prozent,
der Bevölkerung äh ja mindestens einmal geimpft haben. Ähm,
Es gibt immer noch diesen Effekt, dass jeden Tag, wenn Zahlen gemeldet werden, so irgendwas zwischen dreißig und fünfzigtausend Impfungen noch nachgemeldet werden,
als Rom. So selbst wenn man jetzt überhaupt nichts neu impft.
Hätten wir sozusagen dreißig bis fünfzigtausend Impfungen pro Tag, was ich schon mal ganz
ganz gut finde, die also noch on top sind, ne, also die, die sozusagen noch einfach die die ganze Zeit davor umfassen
mit der Tagesmeldung so nichts zu tun haben, also teilweise fallen sie natürlich dann in diesen sieben Tagesschnitt rein. Ich habe mir jetzt nicht im Einzelnen nochmal eine Kurve angeschaut,
wo diese Nachmeldungen stattfinden, die sind relativ,
gestreut, aber dazu äh bräuchte ich eine etwas solidere äh Datenbasis. Leider ist es halt beim Impf-Dashboard genauso wie eben mit den RKI-Daten
es gibt immer nur so einen Tagesdampf, wo alles drin steht, aber die Dinger sind nicht ordentlich äh archiviert und ich habe natürlich am Anfang nicht dran gedacht, das einfach mal mit zu äh schneiden. Ich habe
da auch schon mal gesagt, dass wir's doch mal machen können, aber die haben offensichtlich grade andere Prioritäten.
Ja, wenn man mal guckt, welcher Impfstoff denn jetzt hier überhaupt zum Einsatz kommt, ist natürlich klar, dass äh Björn,
klar, die Nummer eins ist, gar keine Frage, davon gibt's einfach am meisten. Das wird auch so bleiben, bis zum Ende. Moderner,
ergänzt das so ein bisschen und da gibt's kontinuierliche Zahlen, sowohl die Lieferungen steigen an, als auch die Erstimpfung steigen an, als auch die Zweitimpfungen steigen an, aber alles sehr maßvoll.
Und was halt so der Rollercoaster ist, das ist halt irgendwie Astrasinika, das ist so wie alles total unvorhersagbar
wie da jetzt grade Lieferungen kommen, wie auch grade ähm die Kampagne in der Lage ist, Astrasinika jetzt wirklich an die Leute zu bringen. Reden ja auch gleich nochmal da drüber, was derzeit so in der Diskussion ist. In den letzten Tagen haben aber die Impfungen nochmal deutlich angenommen. Also so von so einem Schnitt von fünfzigtausend
jetzt schon äh fast bei bei hunderttausend.
Erstimpfung gelandet, während parallel halt die Zahl der Zweitimpfungen nur mit Asra Sindika jetzt auch schon bei zehntausend im Schnitt ist. Also,
da tut sich was, aber ich glaube, das ist auch wieder so ein Buschfeuer, das wird demnächst ähm wieder verschwinden,
Ja, aber summa summarum, kann man sagen, derzeit läuft's gut. Und meiner Meinung nach wird's auch noch eine ganze Weile ganz gut laufen und es wird spannend werden, so im Juni,
äh ob in irgendeiner Form
zu sagen, noch zusätzlich generiert werden können, ob dazu kommt, ob vielleicht mehr Astra noch geliefert wird, wo es wirklich Bedarf gäbe oder ob wir da äh Biontech nochmal irgendwie ein Kaninchen aus dem Hut zaubert,
sagt so, ach ja übrigens, hier haben wir nochmal oben so und so viel Prozent unserer Produktivität gesteigert in irgendeinem Werk oder was weiß ich äh was noch die Faktoren sein könnten,
um die gelieferte Dosenzahl zu erhöhen. Insgesamt haben sie schon mal ganz gute Zusagen gemacht,
Uns steht dann halt so Anfang Juni, Ende Mai, Anfang Juni, steht ohnehin nochmal eine signifikante Steigerung
der Lieferzahlen an, also von dreieinhalb Millionen geht's dann irgendwie auf knapp fünf Millionen, also eins Komma fünf äh Millionen Dosen. Zusätzlich, die sind aber dann eben auch bitter nötig
weil dann eben einfach die Zahl der Zweitimpfung enorm anzieht. Ja, das ist so grob gesagt das Impfgeschehen derzeit.
Ich glaube, du hattest zehntausend Astra gesagt, pro Tag sind wir, glaube ich, hunderttausend. Ach, Zweitimpfungen, okay.
Also hunderttausend Erstimpfungen und zehntausend Zweidimpfungen. Genau, ne, das sind ja so zwei Zahlen, die man so ein bisschen äh gemeinsam im Blick haben muss.
Okay, ja. Ist auch interessant, das äh sagen wir Anfang Mai äh,
sogar ja offenbar mehr oder fast so viele Erstimpfungen mit moderner gemacht wurden, äh wie mit Astrasinika. Ähm.
Kann zu beginnen. Ach so, im Mai, ja, ja, ja, richtig.
Bin mal so als.
Ja, ja. Ja, bei moderner äh man merkt, äh glaube ich jetzt auch, dass dass äh,
dass die in der Lage ist, langsam ihre Produktion zu steigern. Da wäre wohl auch mehr möglich gewesen. Da ist allerdings in der,
Schweiz nicht rechtzeitig reagiert worden in der also moderner wird vor allem in der Schweiz produziert und da war dann die Politik relativ lahmarschig,
da entsprechende Unterstützung zu geben für den Ausbau der Kapazitäten. Das soll jetzt erfolgen, aber hätte im Prinzip auch schon früher erfolgen können.
Ne
gehört äh jetzt das wohl der Schweiz auch äh derselbe, der ursprüngliche der der Israel Deal angeboten äh worden äh war, sagen wir.
Dem Motto äh sagen, wir bauen auch noch ein zweites Impfstoffwerk und äh ja, impfen dann einmal die Bevölkerung erstmal durch.
Oder mit Bier und Tisch?
Nee, ich glaube, das war moderner, glaube ich. Äh.
Ja, das wäre sehr naheliegend gewesen, weil sie halt schon äh das Zeug da produzieren, aber offensichtlich ist die Schweizer Politik noch ein bisschen haneb
unterwegs als die Deutsche, also das äh ist äh da überhaupt nicht gut gelaufen und jetzt sind's ja auch mit Lockerungen schon wieder ganz weit vorne, also das ist äh kein.
Keine Modellregion für uns.
Mhm.
Liebe dieses Wort.
Keine Modellregion, ja.
Ja auch keine Moderregion.
Ja, aber auch die deutsche Politik ist ja keine Modellregion. Jetzt äh haben wir wieder so eine neue Diskussion an der Backe rund um Astra Zenika. Das ist auch wieder so eine merkwürdige Nummer und man fragt sich manchmal wirklich, was die reitet. Also.
Oh Mann, ja.
Gesundheitsminister Spahn hat jetzt irgendwie angekündigt, dass äh äh jetzt alle.
Begrenzungen fallen sollen, wer denn das jetzt sozusagen bekommen kann, was auch ein bisschen absurd ist, weil offiziell ist der ja nur für äh Ü sechzig freigegeben. Ja, trotz.
Empfohlen, genau richtig so. Letztlich kann man sich halt äh immer noch selber äh entscheiden, es einfach trotzdem zu nehmen, dann ist es halt eine persönliche Entscheidung. Je nachdem, wie das so mit den Ärzten so läuft,
und äh teilweise wird das eben auch angenommen, teilweise eben auch nicht. Irgendwie hat Asra Zinica halt jetzt so einen schlichten Ruf und ich glaube, da kann man irgendwie auch nicht mehr so richtig was dran drehen. Das ist einfach doof gelaufen, obwohl der Impfstoff halt eigentlich super funktioniert.
Jetzt kam aber äh Herr Spahn und meinte irgendwie, na ja, jetzt könnte man ja dann auch nochmal diesen zwölf Wochen Abstand, auf den man sich ja eigentlich erst vor ein paar Monaten geeinigt hatte, äh den könnte man doch jetzt wieder auflösen, sodass irgendwie auch früher Zweitimpfung stattfinden.
Da dachte ich auch so, Alter, was was ist denn das jetzt bitte irgendwie? Also ähm abgesehen davon, dass Asra jetzt gar nicht so gut lieferbar ist.
Vor allem auch die Frage, was das jetzt bitte bringen soll,
Das einzige, was es bringt, ist, dass du quasi auf dem Papier mehr Leute offiziell als zweitgeimpft gelten.
Andererseits ist der Asrasinika-Anteil relativ gering, wenn man das mal mit Bier und Tech vergleicht, also nur der Zahlen wegen, weiß ich nicht. Ist das dann wieder so ein Rentnergeschenk, das jetzt irgendwie die Alten, die mit geimpft wurden, dann,
zwei Monate früher als fertiggeimpft gelten dürfen.
Nee, es wurde halt, also ich, ich denke, es steht im Zusammenhang mit ähm der Urlaubssaison. Und den Erleichterungen für.
Geimpfte.
Ja ja, das wollte ich auch zusammenbringen gerade.
Und die, ja, und jetzt zwölf Wochen Abstand ist äh einfach so, wenn du jetzt nicht schon mit Astra äh geimpft äh bist, so, dann äh äh wird das äh,
mit Astra und äh einfach,
Urlaub äh oder so äh äh wird dann nichts mehr, ja? Und deswegen ist die Befürchtung, dass jetzt die Leute noch weniger Astra haben wollen, weil sie halt,
Astra äh äh nicht in den Urlaub fahren können, wenn sie zwölf Wochen warten müssen auf die auf den zweiten Schritt. So, ich denke.
Das ist äh irgendwie der Vater äh des des Gedankens und.
Wiederum damit zusammenhängt, dass halt äh die Bundesregierung jetzt die ganze Zeit diese Debatte um Impfpass und Aufhebung von Beschränkungen für Geimpfte äh bringen möchte, wo wir auch nochmal separat drüber reden müssen.
Genau und ja ähm es ist aber wohl auch.
Immunologisch nicht sinnvoll. Ähm,
der zwölf mit den zwölf Wochen Abstand hat sich halt gezeigt, dass der tatsächlich den besten Impfschutz bietet, also ist jetzt, ich meine, klar, man kann auch früher, aber so,
Nach zwölf Wochen hat halt wohl den Vorteil, dass äh einfach es wirksamer ist und länger hält.
Und nicht nur wahrscheinlich länger hält der Impfschutz als diese, ich sage mal, wenn man jetzt.
Als diese sechs Wochen äh sagen wir mal nach sechs Wochen statt nach zwölf Wochen die zweite Dosis geben würde, dann
hält die Immunität allein schon sechs Wochen länger, weil man sozusagen eine spätere Auffrischung bekommen hat, aber,
Es geht halt äh deutlich darüber äh hinaus äh so. Ich habe jetzt die Prozentzahlen nicht im Kopf, aber man kann einfach sagen, wenn man also nach zwölf Wochen Astra zwei.
Impfung so ist der Impfschutz einfach besser als äh wenn man das früher macht, die zweite Dosis gibt.
Genau, also wenn wir so nach vier Wochen äh äh zweidimpfen würde, dann wäre der Schutz so bei fünfzig,
Komma irgendwas Prozent und nach zwölf Wochen liegt er dann so bei fünfundachtzig Prozent. Also die Zahlen sprechen da für sich. Alle die jetzt quasi drüber nachdenken, ähm die schon jetzt eine erste Impfung mit Astra Senica haben, dass aus irgendwelchen Gründen vorzuziehen
Ich würde davon absehen. Erstens äh habt ihr jetzt schon mal an sich erstmal genug Schutz. Langfristig.
Ist er dann eben noch sehr viel besser und langlebiger. Und ähm.
Ich glaube auch nicht da dran, dass diese ganze Befreiung durch Impfung äh irgendein nennenswerte Auswirkungen haben wird. Ähm wenn's nicht gerade um internationale Reisen geht. Ähm von daher.
Ist das einfach wieder so etwas, was wieder alles total durcheinander bringt. Und das ist irgendwie das letzte, was wir einfach grade gebrauchen können.
Zumal
gesagt, äh ja, astrei, gerade nur sporadisch kommt und eigentlich ja schon die Debatte läuft äh wenn das so aussieht, als wenn viele Leute
mit BayernTech zweigeimpft werden müssten, die Astra bekommen haben, weil es möglicherweise gar kein Astra gibt.
Ja werden wir sehen.
Dann sollten wir vielleicht mal in dem Zusammenhang auch gleich über diese Impfpass-Diskussion nochmal äh sprechen.
Oh ja.
Äh du hast, du hast da irgendwie mit Linus äh schon was gemacht, habe.
Ja, wir haben da im Lockbuch die ganze Technik des des unfassbares mal durchgesprochen und ich habe da auch äh dann nochmal so diese ganzen.
Probleme besprochen, die halt vor allem mit diesem Bootstrepping äh zu tun haben,
kann man ja vielleicht auch nochmal in der Essenz hier äh wiedergeben, wo ich da das eigentliche Problem sehe.
Versprechen, was jetzt hier gegeben wird, ist ja im Prinzip folgendes. Ja, ihr seid jetzt geimpft.
Es gibt jetzt weniger Gründe, euch Einschränkungen aufzuerlegen, was ihr auch nachvollziehen kann, so grundsätzlich, so ganz allgemein, so aus Prinzip. Ähm.
Wir wollen das jetzt eben auch organisatorisch äh festschreiben und dafür einen Prozess definieren. Und äh der Weg nach draußen ist für uns halt jetzt irgendwie dieser Impfpass.
Sowas gibt's ja auch in Israel. Da gab's diesen grünen Ausweis.
Der Beleg, dass du irgendwie Impfungen bekommen hast oder beide Impfungen bekommen hast, weiß nicht ganz genau und in bestimmten Rahmen war dann äh dieser Nachweis auch der Türöffner für die Teilnahme an irgendwas,
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, im Einzelnen. Es gab da etwas,
wie umfänglich das genutzt wurde und überhaupt angeboten wurde, kann ich nicht sagen, aber das war im Prinzip die Idee. Und auf den ersten Blick ist die ja auch ganz verlockend,
drüber gesprochen so na ja wenn alle nach Malle wollen ja dann lasst euch mal impfen als Ansporn für.
Erhalten einer Impfung. Jetzt haben wir natürlich das Problem, dadurch dass wir jetzt alles so schön verschleppt haben, die Impfkampagne nicht so richtig an Start kam.
Wie er jetzt so zeitlich so ein bisschen in kritischen Bereich kommen, weil Sommerferien nah an, alle schreien nach Urlaub und alle wollen jetzt irgendwie endlich mal so ein bisschen Schluss mit Covid endlich mal über was anderes nachdenken, kann man ja auch total nachvollziehen. Und jetzt kommt sozusagen
Bundesregierung sagt, okay, jetzt, jetzt machen wir hier auch noch so einen geilen Nachweis und damit das dann irgendwie alles total einfach.
Haben sie natürlich einerseits das Problem, dass die Impfkampagne noch nicht so weit ist. Ne, hatten wir eben schon. Andererseits.
Selbst die noch nicht mal zehn Prozent jetzt die äh ihre Zweitimpfung erhalten haben.
Müsste ja jetzt in irgendeiner Form auch Nachweis liefern können. Da gibt's dann halt diesen gelben,
Impfpass oder das Impfbuch, wie ich immer so schön sage, weil so ein richtiger Pass oder Ausweis ist eigentlich nicht wirklich, weil dafür ist er einfach na ja, sagen wir mal, seiner,
seiner Nachweisqualität und vor allem in seiner Felschbarkeit halt eher so auf den siebziger Jahre Level und nicht unbedingt so das, was man heutzutage haben wollen würde, insbesondere äh wo,
uns eh klar ist, dass es einen gewissen Teil der Bevölkerung äh gibt, der sehr wohl nach ähm,
Lockerungen schreit, aber eben nicht bereit ist, dafür auch irgendwie sich selber impfen zu lassen
oder dass die Leute halt schnell dabei sind, sich irgendwie so ein Impfbuch irgendwie auf äh Amazon zu holen oder sich gleich bei uns im Telegramm User äh einen fertig ausgefüllten zu
stellen, der dann irgendwelche Unterschriftenstempel, äh Chargennummern und so weiter nachmacht und ja, solche Impfnachweise erzeugt, wo es eigentlich keine gibt.
So und jetzt könnte man sich natürlich vorstellen, wie soll das jetzt laufen, ne? Also ich will jetzt irgendwie in Urlaub fahren oder ich will an irgendeiner Veranstaltung teilnehmen, also ich will jetzt irgendeine dieser versprochenen Freiheiten für mich in Anspruch nehmen und jetzt möchte ich gerne so einen Nachweis haben.
Dazu muss natürlich dann dieser Fakt dadrin sein. Aber die einzige, das einzige Dokument, was die meisten und noch nicht mal alle,
Leute, die jetzt geimpft werden wurden sind, haben, sind halt, ist halt so Zettelkram ausm Impfzentrum, im Idealfall ein ordentlich ausgefülltes Impfbuch.
Da steht halt ein Name drauf. Ja und eine Unterschrift und einen Stempel und eine Chargennummer,
als Aufkleber nicht mal das ist erforderlich äh und ein Datum. So, das,
im Wesentlichen. Mehr ist da nicht. Gibt's keinen gibt's keinen Aufkleber mit Hologramm oder äh mit irgendwelchen Sicherheitsmerkmalen,
gut, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, die Angst vor solchen Leuten ist vielleicht übertrieben. Es haben viele Leute gesagt, eine Diskussion, die wir die letzte Woche geführt haben, mit ja, okay, gut, kann ja sein, dass Leute das fälschen.
Aber ist die Zahl nicht so gering, dass es keinen Sinn hat, sich groß darüber aufzuregen.
Würde ich sagen, ja, vielleicht?
So sehen, ja? Nur wir reden ja jetzt hier nicht unbedingt von einer Dienstleistungserschleichung, sondern wir reden ja sozusagen auch von der Pandemie und damit ist natürlich auch ein gewisses Risiko für andere Leute ja mit verbunden, weil Leute sich als geimpft.
Nachweisen, die es halt eigentlich tatsächlich nicht äh sind. Also muss man die Frage stellen, gibt's eine Alternative und womit halt jetzt die.
Öffentlichkeit äh kommt, also die Politik, die europäische Politik vor allem, ist halt so dieses
Na ja, digitaler Impfnachweis, das wollten wir doch sowieso schon mal machen. Das ziehen wir jetzt mal alles richtig schön vor und beschleunigen diesen Prozess und führen eben jetzt auch so einen grünen Ausweis, einen konzentrieren wir uns jetzt erstmal nur um diese Eintragung der Coronaimpfung. Vielleicht kriegen wir damit halt
irgendwas automatisiert und erleichtert.
Ja, sowas wird dann immer schnell präsentiert und dann dann hast du Pressekonferenzen und dann wird irgendwie von äh Apps und QR-Codes äh geschwafelt. Nur
Gibt's halt so einen Faktor, den meiner Meinung nach äh so recht keiner so richtig bedacht hat oder wenn's ihn irgendjemand bedacht hat, dann frage ich mich so richtig zu welchen Schlüssen die gekommen sind, weil die Frage ist,
Wie kommt denn eigentlich jetzt diese Information, dass jemand in Deutschland geimpft wurde? Das erste oder das zweite Mal.
In so eine App oder irgend so einen Ausweis oder in so einen was auch immer der Träger ist.
Ja und da wird's halt einfach schwierig, weil der Dokumentationsumfang offenbar,
sehr unterschiedlich ist. Also in den Impfzentren ist zwar viel äh erfasst und ausgefüllt und abgespeichert worden und oft stehen diesem Impfzentrum halt auch entsprechende digitale Systeme zur Seite, keine einheitlichen, aber immerhin gibt's welche.
Wo dann diese Information drin ist und da könnte man in gewisser Hinsicht darüber nachdenken, zu behaupten.
Okay. Die Impfvorgänge sind hier verhältnismäßig gut dokumentiert. Da sind Personennamen, Adressen, Geburtsdaten drin, vielleicht auch noch die Versichertennummer.
Ja? Äh das könnte man da im Prinzip rausziehen. Bei den Ärzten sieht das schon ein bisschen anders aus.
Ja Moment, warte mal. An der Stelle hängt es glaube ich davon ab,
zu welchem Zweck diese Daten erhoben wurden und,
ob die sozusagen, ob die Einwilligung, die jemand gegeben hat, so als diese Impfung stattgefunden hat, dort auch diese Art der Datenverarbeitung überhaupt,
umfasst. So, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht, aber normalerweise ist es so, dass sind halt auch, ich sage mal, Gesundheitsdaten eben sind halt auch besonders zu schützende äh äh Daten und äh.
So es gilt halt ja auch nach wie vor die Zweckbindung dort und
Insofern könnte das nur sagen, auch noch eine zusätzliche Hürde äh darstellen, dass zwar die Leute, dass zwar die Daten da sind, aber die Leute nicht zugestimmt haben
dass die Daten dazu verwendet werden, digitale Impfpässe auszustellen.
Genau, das ist auf jeden Fall auch noch so ein äh Faktor, zumal es halt eins nicht gibt, was offenbar laut Berichterstattung,
Ich habe das aber nur am Rande mitbekommen und nicht sehr viel weiteres dazu gefunden. Es wohl eine Beauftragung des Bundesgesundheitsministeriums ans RKI gibt äh mit dem Aufbau eines sogenannten Impfregisters zu beginnen.
Ich muss mir jetzt nicht viel, glaube ich, nicht viel Kreativität aus dem Hirn heraus saugen, um zu sagen, dieses Register existiert noch nicht,
Ja, also,
da hat das RKI wirklich ganz andere Sorgen, als jetzt irgendwie so eine Infrastruktur hochzuziehen, ähm zumal sowas ja eigentlich auch noch mit einer äh recht umfangreichen politischen Debatte eigentlich noch einhergehen
müsste die, glaube ich, in dem Moment ein bisschen ausgefallen ist. Also, es gibt keine zentrale Registrierung aller Impfvorgänger. Es gibt eine dezentrale Registrierung aller Impfvorgänge,
unterschiedlichen Systemen wird unklaren Datenschutzflex, ne? In Impfzentren,
Das ist wahrscheinlich noch so der zugänglichste Bereich. Schwierig wird's jetzt bei den Hausärzten, weil da liegt diese Information.
Ja, im Idealfall in irgendeiner Praxissoftware hervor, die bei jedem Arzt ein bisschen anders ist und die für solche Anfragen überhaupt nicht gebaut sind.
Und um jetzt also diese Information überhaupt erstmal zu generieren, also dieses ist Person X geimpft worden.
Musst du an diese Quelle gehen. Beziehungsweise irgendjemand muss das tun. Ein Impfzentrum.
Der Betreiber dieser Software.
Müsste diese Information generieren. Das lässt sich da vielleicht noch ganz gut automatisieren. Bei Ärzten reden wir von tausenden von Arztpraxen.
Äh vielleicht nicht hunderten verschiedenen Softwaresystemen, aber doch zumindest so eine ein ziemlicher Blumenstrauß an unterschiedlichen Systemen, in unterschiedlichen Versionen, Zuständen und Ausbaustufen.
Die alle so was noch gar nicht so als Funktion haben. Und ich rede jetzt erstmal nur von der Funktion.
Liste machen von Personen und wer wann wurde diese Person äh,
wo mitgeimpft, das erste und das zweite Mal. Allein nur so eine Liste zu generieren. Das ist schon mal eine große große Herausforderung. Und da haben wir noch nicht davon gesprochen, dass so ein,
digitaler Impfausweis ja nicht einfach nur mit so einer,
Excel-Zeile bedient werden möchte, nein, nein, das ist eine Infrastruktur, die lebt quasi beim Kunden, ja, man träumt, glaube ich, hier von Telefon Apps,
die ich mir installiere und die dann diese Informationen bekommen muss. Wie kommt die dahin? Na ja.
Muss ja dann quasi von dieser Quelle, also der Software der Ärzte oder Software der Impfzentren in irgendeiner Form in diese App reingeladen werden.
Das heißt, diese Ärzte müssen diese Informationen weiterreichen, aber eigentlich funktioniert das Ganze so, dass es ja
digitale Signiersysteme sind, wo im Idealfall halt die Signatur wirklich von der ausführenden Person der Ärzte kommt, ja? Wahrscheinlich wird hier irgendeine Dienstleisterlösung
gewählt werden, dass man da so eine zentrale Meldung macht, aber da wird's dann zu Fehlern kommen, da wird's zu Verzögerungen kommen, Ärzte werden besseres zu tun haben
Wochen und Monate äh brauchen bis diese Information dann auch wirklich ausgespielt werden kann und bis das dann halt wirklich in den Apps ist.
In Deutschland und in Europa da ist der Sommer vorbei. Also dass das jetzt in den nächsten,
fresse ich einen Besen, wenn das, wenn wenn da sozusagen irgendwas auch nur halbwegs nennenswert äh äh schnell vorangehen sollte, zumindest, dass man so ein äh Angebot machen kann, wie alle, die wirklich geimpft wurden, zweimal,
sind jetzt auch auf jeden Fall in der Lage äh diesen Nachweis digital vorweisen zu können.
Ja, wir hatten dann ja auch noch den Weg diskutiert, äh ob sozusagen auch nicht die
kassenärztlichen Vereinigungen, beziehungsweise die Krankenkassen, mit denen ja die Impfungen abgerechnet werden, äh sagen, da äh irgendwie äh
sagen ähm auf diesem Wege äh den massenhaft den Nachweis geführt werden kann, aber da
auch, das gibt's auch mehrere Probleme. Angefangen damit, dass halt nur quartalsweise abgerechnet wird und äh dass also,
im Prinzip, wenn man Pech hat, äh so äh dass drei Monate nach der Zweitimpfung dauert, bis es überhaupt dort vorliegt.
Frühestens frühestens drei Monate, ja. Also wenn du am ersten April geimpft wurdest, dann geht das irgendwie Ende Juni
überhaupt erstmal zu KV. Und bis es dann wirklich bei der Krankenkasse ist und weitergeleitet ist, dann ist halt auch schon wieder vier Monate rum. Und wenn dann eine Zweitimpfung äh im Juli ist, ja, dann reden wir halt von äh September.
Ja plus, dass ja die Daten äh sagen
auch teilweise gar nicht zusammengeführt sind, sondern die Abrechnungsdaten, wenn ich das richtig sehe
gehen halt nur mit einer entsprechenden ID rüber und die Stammdaten liegen da zum Beispiel gar nicht vor, die liegen ja bei der Krankenkasse und so.
Ja, das ist zumindest auch keine schnelle äh äh Lösung da in Sicht, denke ich. Ähm.
Ja, hattest du jetzt noch äh Punkte zu dem zu dem Impfpass.
Man könnte jetzt noch stundenlang drüber äh reden. Ich will jetzt hier nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, aber im Kern kann man einfach festhalten,
So einfach wird das nicht werden. Also ich glaube da nicht so richtig dran, dass sowas digitales kommt. Da aber eben dieses Versprechen jetzt im Raum ist
einfach dieser gelbe Zettel, den viele auch noch nicht haben. Ja, der auch oft bei grade bei Immobilien äh
Impf ähm Teams, ja, ist teilweise sehr wenig dokumentiert worden und oft auch Leute überhaupt nicht mit so einem Zettel ausgestattet worden
da wird's also extrem viel nachträgliche Bewegungen geben und dann wollen das alle im Sommer und dann die Ärzte auch mal im Urlaub und das wird alles dauern.
Plus, also je länger ich mir, je länger ich über dieses ganze Impfpassthema nachdenke. Ganz unabhängig,
von jetzt den ganzen praktischen Problemen und das ist äh wie sagt man äh nicht so aussieht, als wenn das eine schnelle Lösung für irgendwas äh wäre. Ganz abgesehen davon.
So habe ich mittlerweile fundamentale Zweifel an der,
Notwendigkeit und an der äh Sinnhaftigkeit des Ganzen, weil ich weiß nicht, ob man das wirklich vergleichen kann, äh so, aber ich meine,
Stell dir vor, ich kann in ein Auto steigen, Schlüssel reinstecken und losfahren, ja?
Muss dazu nicht geimpft sein, aber ich brauche, ich muss dazu keinen Führerschein haben, so, ja.
Nichts. Ich kann halt einfach mit einem Auto in der Gegend rumfahren. Und ich kann mich sogar betrinken und mit dem Auto
rumfahren, ja? Hier gibt's hindert mich nichts dran, da gibt's kein, also normalerweise jedenfalls kein digitales System, was mein Atemalkohol misst
und äh ja und es gibt auch keinen Führerscheinkartenleser, den ich irgendwo reinstecken muss in das Auto, um nachzuweisen, äh dass ich jetzt mit diesem Auto fahren
äh darf, sondern das Ganze läuft halt darüber, dass halt na ja.
Es wird halt ab und zu kontrolliert und es gibt halt eine Strafänderung und dann fliegt man halt auf und dann wird man halt bestraft dafür oder,
ja. Ähm so das ist das, ich sage mal, das ist das Prinzip, äh was wir bei Autos äh haben. Ähm.
Und ich weiß jetzt nicht äh,
ob jetzt von einem, ich sage mal, also von einem Fahrer ohne Führerschein eine größere Gefahr ausgeht,
als äh von einem Ungeimpften, der irgendwo äh äh rumläuft, ja.
Alles ein bisschen der Vergleich, aber grundsätzlich so äh ich sage mal, beim Auto würden wir uns, glaube ich,
echt dagegen ganz schön, also wenn man's ganz schön aufregen, wenn plötzlich sagen jetzt die Führerscheine, dann alle digitalisiert werden und alle Autos sitzen in den äh äh einen Kartenleser kriegen
ja, um äh äh damit zu fahren. Also,
Ja, vielleicht, ich, ich weiß es nicht. Äh, ich meine, auf Dauer, ja, klar, irgendwie,
digitalisieren halt alles mögliche, aber ähm ich glaube, dieser gelbe Zettel, ich meine, wenn die Pandemie dann erstmal vorbei ist, äh habe ich das Gefühl, wird das ganze Thema erst mal wieder,
in Vergessenheit geraten und diese, ja, gelben Karten,
Ausweise oder Zettel werden wieder in allen Schubladen verschwinden, da wo sie die letzten zwanzig Jahre gelegen haben. Das ist so ein bisschen,
Ja, weiß ich nicht, meine, vielleicht ähm etwas saloppe oder.
Sicht auf das Thema oder äh ja.
Ist fast dran. Ich meine, die Frage ist, wie wird sich so der der internationale Reiseverkehr entwickelt, ne, also Australien zeigt ja jetzt schon eine relativ harte Kante,
sagt so, na okay, also vielleicht behalten wir diese ganzen Regelungen, also Einschränkungen bei Einreise, äh et cetera bis bis Mitte nächsten Jahres noch aufrecht.
Neuseeland weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau und andere äh keine Ahnung wie die das jetzt planen und äh so halten und sich das so denken. Aber damit können sie auf jeden Fall was zu tun haben. Der ganze Reiseverkehr innerhalb Europas
generell buchen von Reisen, ja, auch was so online läuft, Flüge, et cetera, das mag halt schon in irgendeiner Form
nach so einem Nachweis schreien, so. Aber ansonsten bin ich da ganz bei dir. Ich denke auch, dass.
Jetzt, wo das so ein Thema ist. Uns geht eigentlich im Wesentlichen um Urlaub, ja. Ist es halt eigentlich noch
Zu früh, da wird also dieser Nachweis nicht groß kommen oder wird zumindest ausreichend betrogen werden und danach äh im Herbst wird's nicht mehr so eine große Rolle spielen. Allein schon, weil dann ja auch wirklich auch alle geimpft sind.
Wo es dann irgendwie auch ein bisschen Quatsch ist nach irgendwelchen Ausweisen zu fragen, die potenziell dann irgendwie jeder hat oder wo es dann auch nicht mehr so eine große Rolle spielt,
dass die Leute, die sich halt jetzt partout nicht impfen lassen wollen oder können, die wir einfach auf dies hinauslaufen wird, so oder so, äh ja, das ist dann zwar nicht gut von denen.
Also sofern's ihre Schuld ist, nur.
Wir haben dann eben die Pandemie zumindest soweit im Griff erstmal, dass sie nicht mehr das Problem ist, was sie was sie derzeit eben gerade noch ist.
Dann geht das Thema auch schnell wieder weg. Ja. Trotzdem bin ich der Meinung, so ein Impfregister an sich, ja, auch wenn's da viele Fragen zum Datenschutz gibt.
Ist an sich eine gute Idee. Wir brauchen einfach einen guten Überblick da drüber, wie das so aussieht und wir haben gesehen, hier auch äh schon schon vor der Corona-Pandemie äh grade hier in unserem Stadtteil
Prenzlauer Berg äh gab's ja immer diesen diesen Witz äh so ja, wo wir uns treffen,
ja wir können uns in Prenzlberg treffen, ich bin geimpft, weißt du? Weil die einfach so Masernausbruch und so was ja schon wieder hochkam, ne? Durch die
und
denke ich mal, ist in diesem ganzen Infektionsbereich ohnehin noch eine Menge zu tun und wir tun gut da dran, da einen ordentlichen Überblick zu haben für also einen wissenschaftlichen Überblick für die Politik, um entsprechend handeln zu können.
Und irgendwie müssen wir das gelöst bekommen. Ob jetzt dieser Vorstoß mit diesem Impfpass hier äh.
Hilfreich ist, weiß ich nicht, habe da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel so oder so sehe ich noch nicht, dass das jetzt relativ schnell kommen wird.
Na ja, ja, also wir haben, werden sehen, äh ich ich denke, am am Ende, ja, äh wird,
jeder mit Zetteln kommen und äh.
Es werden Leute auffliegen, die da, ja, mit Fälschungen unterwegs äh sind, weil,
meistens ist es auch so, dass dann die Leute genommen werden, die die Dinger geliefert haben und dann äh äh werden die Leute halt, äh die dort Kunden waren, äh so äh ja
die können dann halt Stress äh kriegen und äh ja oder.
Das könnte dann auch schon ausreichend abschreckend wirken, weil das ist dann auch nicht so lustig. Also ich glaube, wenn man mit so einem Vergehen äh erwischt wird, so Dokumentenfeld-Show und das Ganze so in pandemischen Zeiten, das das könnte schon ganz schön wehtun.
Also Urkundenfell, also da da kommt, glaube ich, einiges äh zusammen so und äh insofern,
Ich denke, das Problem ist gerade im Moment über alle angemessenen Proportionen hinaus äh aufgeblasen und wird, glaube ich,
äh in ein paar Monaten wieder in sich zusammenfallen und dann redet keiner mehr drüber.
Zum Ausklang vielleicht noch ein paar äh Meldungen zu Impfstoffen, paar paar gute Nachrichten und nochmal so eine generelle Debatte vielleicht für den
Schluss. Zunächst einmal gab's in dem aktuellen RKI Bullitar, dem epidemiologischen Bullta,
erscheint das eigentlich wöchentlich? Nee.
Nee, nee, das ist äh alle paar Monate oder so. Das ist also schon immer ein Event.
Ah okay, gut, dann dieses Event gab's jetzt äh ist halt gerade wieder ein neues rausgekommen mit dem offiziellen Datum des äh zwölften Mai, die wir noch gar nicht haben
online vorab, wie das so schön heißt und dort äh gibt's halt dann auch,
ähm ja Informationen darüber, wie gut eine Covid-neunzehn-Impfung vor Infektionen schützt und
da haben sie dann ähm mal ihre eigenen Erkenntnisse veröffentlicht und wenig überraschend fallen die Zahlen ganz gut aus, die sie dort nennen.
Sie meinen die Effektivität der äh Impfung mit den zugelassenen Impfstoffen liegt nach vollständiger Impfserie zwischen achtzig und neunzig Prozent, sowohl für Schutz,
vor jeglichen wie auch als Symptomatischen Infektionen,
Personen, die trotz Impfung, PCR positiv getestet wurden, haben eine signifikant geringere Viruslast und eine kürzere Virusausscheidung, also selbst wenn man geimpft wurde.
Sich infiziert hat, so dass auch ein PCR-Test das nachweisen kann, ist man trotzdem nicht auf dem selben Level wie jemand ohne Impfung, eben weil die Viruslast sehr viel geringer ist und das auch alles nicht so lange dauert.
Und die Daten äh legen nahe, dass die Info, die Verbreitung des Virus erheblich reduziert.
Vollständig geimpfte Personen spielen laut dem RKI bei der Verbreitung des Virus, voraussichtlich keine wesentliche Rolle mehr.
Das ist ihre Aussage.
Genau und keine wesentliche äh sollte man dann eben so lesen, äh aber auch äh dass es halt äh ja trotzdem zu Ansteckungen kommen kann.
Aber nichts, was jetzt mit so einem äh Höllenerbe daher kommt, dass es halt jetzt wieder so pandemisch wird, so. Man kann halt Leute anstecken, aber es ist keine kein ist kein Superspreader mehr.
Ja, das heißt, pandemisch äh ist es halt auf jeden Fall wirksam, aber äh so ähm eben im Einzelfall äh kann's dann trotzdem noch schiefgehen.
Klar.
Ja, dann gibt's auch noch ganz gute Nachrichten per äh Paper zu den einzelnen Impfstoffen, bei Biontech äh gibt's nochmal eine Untersuchung, wie denn das so mit den Mutanten äh ist in dem äh in dem Paper wird,
nachgewiesen,
dass der Biotech Impfstoff neunzig Prozent Wirksamkeit auch gegen die britische Muttante zeigt, also die wir jetzt vor allem in Deutschland haben, die B eins eins sieben Muttante
fünfundsiebzig Prozent Wirksamkeit zeigt gegen die südafrikanische, also die B dreizehn einundfünfzig, Mutante
aber an beiden Fällen, man wird ja immer schnell bei diesen Prozentzahlen kommt man ja immer gleich so in Panik, so oh Gott, was ist, wenn ich in die andere Gruppe falle, ja? Diese Wirksamkeit
diese Effektivität, die äh bezeichnet halt immer um wie viel reduzierter die Wirkung äh letztlich ist,
deswegen bedeutet es nahezu hundertprozentiger Schutz vor schweren Verläufen auch mit diesen,
Daten, das sind Daten aus Katar mit über dreihundertachtzigtausend teilnehmenden Personen und das sei äh besonders aussagekräftig. Die ähm.
Bestätigt auch nochmal die Wichtigkeit der zweiten Dosierung.
Denn äh nach der ersten Dosis betrug die Wirksamkeit zum Beispiel gegen die südafrikamutante nur siebzehn Prozent. Mit der zweiten Impfung,
fünfundsiebzig Prozent. Das gilt jetzt, wie gesagt, für den Biotech Impfstoff.
Ähnliche Informationen gibt's auch von Novaks. Das ist ja ein Impfstoff, den wir bisher noch nicht gesehen haben. Das ist dieser Proteinbasierte Impfstoff.
Bin ich noch mal gespannt, ob wir den in Europa überhaupt sehen werden. Ich habe den jetzt auf den äh Prognosen, Lieferprognosen noch nicht gesehen,
Mal gucken. Ähm.
Dort ist gegen diese südafrikabutante getestet worden und da ist zumindest von fünfzig Prozent Wirksamkeit die äh Rede und moderner,
rausgehauen indem sie angekündigt haben, dass sie einen angepassten Impfstoff gegen die Südafrika-Mutante äh entwickelt haben und auch schon getestet haben und er.
Besonders wirksam sei und die Daten dazu werden in den nächsten Tagen veröffentlicht. Das lässt sich jetzt hier quasi noch an dieser Stelle nicht quantifizieren.
Ja, das mal so zwischendurch. Ähm moderner äh hatte er auch vor einiger Zeit, das haben wir ja hier auch besprochen, auch gesagt, so, dass sie ihre Patente nicht ähm.
Forssen wollen, während der Zeit der Pandemie, wo man sich halt auch so dachte so, ja, okay, mhm,
gut. Was heißt das jetzt? Und wir hatten ja hier auch schon mal ausführlicher diskutiert darüber, was es eigentlich bedeutet, diese MRNA Impfstoffe zu produzieren. Also dass dieser ganze Vorgang ein relativ komplexer ist, dass die Technik dafür,
Prinzip noch entwickelt wird, dass überhaupt gar keine remate Technologie gibt im medizinisch-technischen Bereich
wo man sagen kann, guten Tag, bauen sie mir mal hier so eine MRNA Fabrik hin, of the sheve, weil das halt einfach bisher,
wesentlichen so zusammengestecktes Labormaterial war und dieser ganze Prozess erst noch erfunden wird und das ganze Know-How eigentlich gerade erst generiert wird, sodass man eben schon immer eigentlich schnell,
sich das so anschaut zu dem Schluss kommen konnte, bringt's eigentlich was? Äh wenn diese Patente jetzt fallen.
Wird also wird dadurch wirklich irgendwas einfacher auf einmal, ja? Oder nicht?
Und das Ganze, diese ganze Debatte hat jetzt nochmal neue Diskussions ähm Befeuerung gefunden. Nicht nur, weil es ja, sagen wir mal, aus diesem Zero-Covid-Bereich schon länger gefordert wird. Das ist ja irgendwie äh eine sinnvolle Maßnahme wäre
Nee, jetzt hat auch noch der Präsident der USA Joe Biden bekannt gegeben, dass er irgendwie.
Weiß nicht ganz genau, was das jetzt für eine Verfügung ist. Das halt äh diese Impfstoff-Patente fallen sollen.
Ja, also ich habe dazu heute auch auch getwittert ähm so.
Dass ich das für 'ne Luftnummer halte. So und.
Angefangen schon mal damit also.
Entweder, wenn man jetzt ja, entweder Impfstoffpatente sind gut, im Sinne von, sie sorgen dafür, äh dass mehr Impfstoffe, bessere Impfstoffe.
Verfügbar sind. So. Oder sie sind schlecht.
Ja, wenn sie gut sind, äh so, dann gibt es keinen Grund, die jetzt auszusetzen.
Wenn sie aber schlecht sein sollten, dann.
Ja ist 'nen Aussetzen genauso Quatsch dann muss man's halt abschaffen und nicht aussetzen. Aber aussetzen macht irgendwie,
in beiden Fällen nicht äh keinen Sinn. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, ah, aber das ist jetzt nur wegen der Pandemie.
Ja? Ähm ich meine, wann sonst? Wofür sonst braucht man irgendwie Impf,
Stoffe, also wenn's, ich meine, es wäre ja auch so ah, nee, wir machen halt unsere Regeln jetzt äh so über Impfstoffe, aber in,
Pandemien gelten die jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr, weil die irgendwie offensichtlich nicht für Pandemien geeignet sind irgendwie, als ob irgendwie Patente jetzt pandemiefeindlich
werden. Sind sie vielleicht? Ich weiß es nicht. Der Punkt ist das ist 'ne ob.
Jetzt das jetzt gut ist oder schlecht, Patente, generell in bestimmten Bereichen.
Ich denke, das lässt sich nicht eindeutig beantworten. Ich bin dem, weil.
Wer damals so in mit den, mit den Piraten und so Urheberrecht und war das ja auch so eine politische Forderung und ich habe versucht, damals dann auch äh zu gucken, so die.
Ja rauszufinden so wie ist das denn mit den Patenten.
Eigentlich, weil äh also unten jetzt nicht so einen rein nach Bauchgefühl, na ja, irgendwie, nee, Patente sind blöd, weil äh Konzerne und so und äh ja, das ist damit macht man sich zu einfach
Mitmach. Also ähm.
Und äh ja, ich und ich habe genug Dinge gefunden, so genug,
Argumente und auch äh ja, stichhaltige Argumente äh sowohl für als auch gegen äh die Existenz äh von Patenten. Aber der Punkt ist nun mal
wir haben nun mal Patente so und das System ist halt im Moment darauf ausgerichtet, dass es die.
Die Patente so. Und wenn man das jetzt abschaffen will, braucht man halt einfach bessere Argumente, als wenn man's einfach nur beibehalten will. So, das ist also so. Und die besseren Argumente,
sehe ich halt äh tatsächlich leider gerade auch nicht oder die zwingenden Argumente. So, aber,
Der eigentliche, sozusagen Punkt ist, dass die Patente auch überhaupt gar kein Hindernis äh äh darstellen so für einen Staat oder für die USA. Ähm.
Patente kann man kaufen so,
oder lizensieren. Der Staat könnte die Firmen kaufen, lizensieren, es gibt genug Möglichkeiten auch ähm sagen äh also die meisten Staaten haben auch Gesetzgebung, das so in bestimmten.
Notlagen oder für bestimmte Zwecke üblicherweise Krieg,
so oder aus Sicherheitsgründen eben auch Patente beschlagnahmt und äh verheimlicht äh werden dürfen, aber die Patentinhaber müssten halt in allen Fällen entschädigt werden.
Ja so und äh wahrscheinlich ist es keine Ahnung, ob das in den USA überhaupt,
äh ginge, aber in Deutschland wäre das, glaube ich, verfassungs äh mäßig und vermutlich in den USA auch gar nicht möglich jetzt, Firmen
dazu zu zwingen oder die Gesetze so zu ändern, dass und die die.
Den Firmen, die Firmen nicht zu entschädigen. Also wenn man das abschaffen will, müsste man halt einfach nur aufhören, neue Patente anzunehmen
Und dann hat sich das in zwanzig Jahren erledigt, ja, dann sind die alle ausgelaufen, dann ist gut. So, aber äh das.
Ja? Aber das, was da gerade passiert, ich ich weiß nicht, äh,
ob da irgendwas sinistrisch äh dahinter steckt, dass jetzt, keine Ahnung, die USA, dass jetzt Pfeißer irgendwie
ähm nicht an Bier und Tech zahlen will und deswegen äh halt äh
ja deswegen jetzt die Patente ausgesetzt werden sollen oder ich.
Ich denke, also die meisten Patente liegen in dem Fall sogar bei moderner, also moderner hat ja auch einiges an Biotech lizenziert, aber das ist wahrscheinlich und diese ganzen Zutaten, die man dazu braucht, sind ja auch teilweise patentbehaftet.
Genau, also da ist dann, also die Kette geht ja weiter, die Großteil aus der ganzen Lieferkette äh sind ja auch noch patentiert, dass es nicht damit getan jetzt die Patente
ähm irgendwie den Impfstoff, sondern auch gucken die Grundstoffe teilweise sind halt super teuer
und so, aber sagen, als also meine wahrscheinlichste Vermutung äh wie es jetzt dazu gekommen ist, ist äh ich sage mal der beiden hat ja jetzt
auch äh jede Menge, sage mal, progressive Linke da jetzt in seinem Team. So würde ich das nennen,
und ich glaube, äh dass das äh sagen eine eine Folge davon ist, dass halt ja dort äh,
wie
sich jetzt äh irgendwelche, ich nenne es mal progressiven Linken äh durchgesetzt haben und ihnen diese Flausen in den Kopf gesetzt haben, ohne das aber bis zum Ende durchzudenken. So, aber es
klingt halt erstmal natürlich ganz toll, ja äh äh irgendwie freie Patente und,
ja, wenn man das will, also ich bin eh der Meinung, äh dass da ohnehin äh mehr Steuergelder,
in Forschung, in Grundlagenforschung, aber auch in Medikamenten und Impfstoffentwicklung gehen sollte und zwar nicht.
Nur wenn Pandemie ist oder erst in der Pandemie, sondern dass dort in vielen Fällen eben auch der Markt nicht funktioniert.
Ähm so äh und äh dass eben zum Beispiel Impfstoffe für bestimmte oder ähm,
Medikamente für bestimmte Krankheiten, die nur Minderheiten betreffen oder wo es nur relativ wenig Kranke gibt, wobei relativ wenig dann zig oder hunderttausende sein kann oder Millionen weltweit, aber
so, äh dass äh dort halt einfach nichts entwickelt wird, weil der Markt einfach zu klein ist. Und ich finde, da ist es auch staatlicher Aufgabe. Sagen,
mehr Geld äh rein äh äh reinzutun. Ähm ja ähm.
Also ich denke halt auch, wenn man, wenn das Ziel ist, jetzt möglichst viel Impfstoffe in die Welt zu bekommen.
Ja, dann ist der einfachste und naheliegendste Weg dahin einfach, kauft die den Firmen ab.
Lasst sie die produzieren, dass sie mit dem Geld auch die entsprechenden Produktionszentren überhaupt erstmal aufbauen können. Und dann liefern wir einfach diesen Impfstoff in alle Länder, die sich das nicht selber leisten können.
Das ist echt noch das geringste Problem. Also das Geld, was man jetzt dafür aufbringen muss, ist äh für die Welt kein,
Thema. Ja, es ist immer noch Vielfaches teurer. Die Pandemie weiter laufen zu lassen und permanent uns dieser Gefahr auszusetzen, dass eben auch so wichtige äh Faktoren,
wie zum Beispiel die indische Wirtschaft jetzt auf einmal ausfallen.
Ne? Durch die Situation, die es äh dort gibt. Und genauso können natürlich auch kleinere Länder in irgendeiner Form ein Problem darstellen,
und wenn's nur ist, weil dieses Land Marktführer ist.
Zulieferung und eines wichtigen Rohstoffs. Oder auch Medikaments.
Also China ist äh ja nicht der weltgrößte Exporteur für jetzt Medikamentengrundstoffe, nicht unbedingt für Medikamente, aber da sind die auch ganz gut dabei und Indien.
Sind, sind sind halt auch groß dabei so,
Aber ich habe mit beiden Ländern, ehrlich gesagt, auch Probleme, äh weil äh ähm dort ähm ich meine, da ist sehr viel Produktion hin abgewandert.
Aber warum? Äh ja weil's dort billiger ist und warum ist es dort billiger? Weil dort Umwelt und Sozialdumping betrieben wird.
Ja, das kann eigentlich kann das auch keine Lösung sein und ich deswegen wäre ohnehin äh notwendig äh äh finde ich, dass man eigentlich einen einen Zoll- und Handelssystem hat,
was halt äh äh dafür sorgt, dass eben äh Länder mit niedrigen,
mit niedrigeren äh ja Sozial- und Umweltstandards, dass deren Produkte einfach verteuert werden, so um eben genau das zu verhindern,
dass wir in anderen Ländern Umweltzerstören, ja?
Und das ist halt äh und dann am Ende äh auch noch äh Medikamentenknappheit deswegen haben äh oder wie im Fall von China, ich meine den Chinesen traue ich einfach nicht über den Weg, die punschen halt
alles äh so dort. Und es gab auch entsprechende Skandale mit Medikamenten, also Valsartan zum Beispiel. Das ist so ein Stichwort, so ein Skandal, äh wo sie.
Halt äh ja verunreinigte äh Medikamente äh geliefert haben, die dann auch in Verkehr gekommen sind.
Nicht das, also normalerweise versuchen die Chinesen die Sachen für den Export äh dann versuchen sie halt möglichst gut Qualitätskontrolle zu machen, aber fürs Inland
äh hat man das Gefühl, nehmen sie dann auch viel von dem Schrott, der bei der äh Qualitätskontrolle äh äh für den Export ins Ausland,
wegfällt durchfällt,
und äh ja und ich meine auch in China trotz der Geheimhaltung äh sie kann dann immer wieder Nachrichten ja über
äh eben auch äh zum Beispiel ja Impf und Medikamentenskandal, also mit gepunchten Impfstoffen und mit gepunchten Medikamenten und ich meine, machen sogar gepunchtes Bier, ja. Äh also
wo ja, was aus irgendwelchen zusammengemixten Chemikalien äh äh besteht. Ja ähm.
Und ähm bis hinzu, ich meine, das ekligste, von dem ich gehört habe, aber dann machen wir das auch Schluss sein ist, ähm,
dass äh äh die halt Fette aus der Kanalisation aufbereiten, um darin dann wieder Nahrung äh sagen zu frittieren und zu grillen.
Gott, lass uns wieder.
Vielleicht diese englischen,
Klöße, kennst diese Fettklöße, die sich in der Kanalisation ansammeln, genau. Äh die werden dort äh wieder sozusagen recycelt, aber nicht so, wie man sich das vorstellt, sondern halt, na ja.
Jetzt kommen wir ja wieder an.
Mhm. Mhm.
Wir sind auch langsam am Ende der Sendung, also Achtung, wir müssen jetzt hier mal wieder äh den positiven Spin reinkriegen. Also ich fasse mal kurz zusammen
Das war, glaube ich, relativ einig. Die Auflösung und Aufhebung und auch nur temporäre Aussetzungen von Impfstoff, Patenten bringt in der aktuellen Situation einfach mal gar nix, zumindest nicht, wenn das Ziel ist
maximal schnell möglichst viele Impfstoffe äh in die Welt zu bringen.
Noch ein Aspekt, äh das hat so viele Aspekte, ich meine äh also ja, zusammenfassend können wir, glaube ich, ähm,
so die meisten Länder können keine Impfstoffe produzieren, nicht wegen der Patente, sondern weil sie's schlichtweg nicht können. So, das kann man, glaube ich, und da ändern auch eben Patente nichts dran.
Also nicht, weil sie es nicht könnten, sondern weil sie einfach derzeit noch nicht die Technologie das Personal äh und den den Flow von Materialien organisiert bekommen können, der erforderlich ist.
Weil sie auch nicht die Wohnungen oder die nicht den Lebensstandard haben, den sie bräuchten, um die,
wenn sie dort in ausreichender Zahl die Experten beherbergen wollten, im Land, die qualifiziert genug sind, um diese Arbeiten durchzuführen, ja. Das heißt, du musst im Endeffekt, ja, musst du äh damit Länder, äh, mein
oder viele Länder so ärmere oder weniger entwickelte Länder müsstest du überhaupt erst entwickeln, damit die in der Lage sind äh
ja? Oder klar, du kannst das da irgendwie hintransplantieren oder so und ich mein, passiert ja auch, so mit Technologietransfer und so weiter, aber ja, selbst in Europa, wenn du dir anguckst.
Welche Länder jetzt irgendwie mitwirken äh an der Impfstoffproduktion und so, ja. Also.
Das ist vor allen Dingen bei MRNA, Impfstoffen ja.
Sehr kleiner Club.
Man das komplett vergessen. Es gibt sicherlich einfacher herzustellende Impfstoffe, so die weniger Technologie erfordern, also sozusagen eine Variante, aber.
Für jetzt wirklich Entwicklungsländer oder Krisenregionen, wenn man die halt auch durchimpfen will oder generell Länder.
Oder mit schlechten Gesundheitssystemen, dann möchte man eventuell auch ganz andere Impfstoffe haben, die zum Beispiel anders verabreicht werden, also sie wo du keine sterilen Spritzen brauchst, sondern die halt äh,
dann,
ja inhaliert oder in die Nase gespritzt oder geschluckt werden können und solche Impfstoffe sind auch in der Entwicklung und Erprobung soweit ich weiß sogar, ja, die du nicht spritzen,
Most gegen Covid. Das ist nochmal ein ganz anderer Aspekt. Also anderen Worten einfach zu sagen, ah wir machen jetzt die Patente weg. Also ähm.
Ne? Ich würde das begrüßen, wenn man jetzt sagen das Patentsystem nochmal daraufhin,
wirklich untersucht und umkrempelt, welche Arten äh denn von, ich sage mal, Technologie,
weitesten Sinne,
denn überhaupt patentierbar sind, ich meine es gibt ja vieles was nicht patentierbar ist aber es gibt halt so diesen Bereich so umstritten ja soll man überhaupt Moleküle patentieren können äh oder Gensequenzen
patentieren oder so. Das ist das sind da oder Software Patente und.
Ähm ja, also da denke ich, äh ist auf jeden Fall eine Debatte sinnvoll, äh aber die müsste dann, oder sollte dann zunehmen.
Dauerhaften äh Veränderung äh führen und nicht jetzt irgendwie, ich meine.
Aussetzen, bis die Pandemie war. Ich meine, wer investiert denn, ich meine, das ist so eine andere Sache, wer investiert denn wirklich in Produktionsanlagen äh.
Um auf der Basis von, ich sage mal, ausgesetzten Patenten irgendwas zu produzieren, wo aber irgendwann die nicht mehr ausgesetzt sind,
dann kann ich entweder meine Fabrik zumachen oder äh dann ist doch, ich meine, Kapital oder Investition in irgend,
was äh hängen halt massiv auch vom vom Risiko ab, beziehungsweise die erwartete Kapitalrendite, ja? Und niemand wird irgendwie jetzt in,
äh äh Geschichten, die dann auch noch,
nichts abwerfen investieren ja also funktioniert Kapital, Allokation nicht nirgendwo außer,
ja, wenn es übergeordnete Dinge da gibt.
Ja und die Patentgeber sind ja auf jeden Fall auch immer deine größten Konkurrenten, ne? Also weil ich meine, es wird immer so sein, dass die äh Pharmaunternehmen, die halt jetzt hier diese Patente halten, natürlich vor allem auch ein Interesse an der Produktion haben. Das müssen die ja sogar tun
weil sie sonst ja diese ganze Technologie überhaupt nicht im Griff behalten können. Das ist ja nicht so die erfindest das und dann ja okay, wir haben jetzt hier Impfstoff, wer will denn mal produzieren
hier bitte schön, da könnt ihr euch ja das PDF runterladen, kostet irgendwie dreißig Millionen Dollar pro Jahr und dann könnt ihr mal machen. So funktioniert das halt einfach nicht. Also ich glaube
Diese ganze Debatte ist ähm ein bisschen verquer und ein bisschen aufgeheizt und äh,
Ich verstehe ja so eine gewisse Grundskepsis gegenüber Konzernen und die Pharmaindustrie ist sicherlich auch äh wie alle großen Konzerne
äh an vielen Stellen nicht ganz sauber, aber man kann auch, um ihn mal nicht von Hand weisen, dass jetzt so durch die,
medizinische Industrialisierung schon so als Gesellschaft so ein gewissen Benefit kann man dem Ganzen jetzt nicht absprechen, ne? Also es ist jetzt so per se nicht ganz so böse eigentlich alles.
Nee, aber welchen Teil man davon, ich sage mal, privat wirtschaftlich organisiert und wie man die Steuerung äh macht und äh so weiter,
letztlich.
Hängt es mit Gesundheitssystem zusammen und das ist halt äh so Gesundheitssystem in all ihren Varianten ähm ja äh das ist so ein komplexes Thema äh ja
und.
Das ist das Fass, was wir heute nicht mehr aufmachen.
Nee. Definitiv.
Ich würde bisher vorschlagen, Pavi, wir können jetzt das Thema auch mal äh zumachen und diese Sendung eigentlich auch, denn jetzt ist erstmal alles gesagt für heute.
Vielleicht ein kleiner Ausblick, wie ähm wir es gerne tun. Ich fange mal an. Habe ich ja im Prinzip schon gesagt. Derzeit,
entwickelt sich die ganze Impfkampagne sehr gut. Viele von euch mögen vielleicht noch so äh auf dieser Position sein, oh Gott, bis ich dran komme, ist irgendwie, dann fällt schon wieder Schnee.
Meine Erfahrung ist äh so Anekdote, dass derzeit eine Menge Termine purzeln und ähm,
schnell so einen Dominoeffekt da äh einsetzt, so ein bisschen wie Kita kriegen in im Prenzlauer Berg. Alle tragen sich auf alle Wartelisten ein und in dem Moment, wo die erste Kita zusagt, ähm
tragen sich ganz viele Leute wieder aus diesen Wartelisten aus. Sprich.
Das wird jetzt alles relativ schnell gehen. Ja, wir haben irgendwie über fünfhunderttausend äh neue Impfungen pro Tag halbe Millionen Leute,
Bevölkerung von achtzig Millionen, das ist schon was, was man spürt. Sprich, wir werden jetzt eine Beschleunigung sehen und äh ihr solltet euch drum kümmern.
Das Motto ist für sich, wer kann, ja? Derzeit ist halt die Nachfrage noch sehr viel größer als das Angebot,
Das wird sicherlich auch noch eine Weile so bleiben, aber die Möglichkeiten sind da
schaut nach, nach Terminen bei euren Impfzentren, fragt bei euren Haus, äh Ärztin nach und dann äh kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass ihr da auch bald ähm.
Aufrückt und auch Termine bekommt.
Wichtig ist vielleicht im Moment, sagen bei euren Hausärzten, weil äh im Moment sagen, irgendwo.
Ja bei 'nem Arzt jetzt
der nicht der Hausarzt ist, gerade die werden die sind im Moment komplett geflutet mit mit Anfragen und das ist glaube ich so ja
also irgendwo einfach auf Verdacht anrufen äh bei einem bei einem Arzt äh äh glaube ich sollte man noch ein paar Wochen warten.
Oder wie siehst du das?
Das ist äh sicherlich jetzt nicht unbedingt besonders gewinnbringend, aber man hat unter Umständen auch mehr äh als ähm,
Nur eine Ärztin zur Auswahl, ja, also man hat auch Kinderärzte und so weiter. Man muss halt einfach mal schauen, wo wird überhaupt geimpft, aber überall, wo man eben geführt ist
Ja, äh lohnt es sich, nachzufragen. Ich würde auch mal Kinderärzte äh explizit mal mit reinnehmen, die ihr vielleicht auch irgendwann anfangen mit der Impferei, wenn's für die Kinder auch eröffnet ist,
Einfach mal äh bei Terminen, die man unter Umständen sowieso hat, nachfragen
Ja und ansonsten einfach die Terminportale einfach mal frequentieren, weil ich glaube, da wird jetzt in zunehmendem Maße was frei werden. Macht euch nicht verrückt, ähm aber auf jeden Fall schon mal Augen offen halten. Geht bald los.
Infektionsgeschehen. Tja, da heißt es einfach weiterhin, haltet euch noch ein bisschen zurück. Da müssen wir jetzt nochmal einen Monat durchhalten.
Ja, das ist äh sieht sieht so aus, ja und wie vorhin äh schon gesagt, zusammengefasst.
Ähm,
es hängt jetzt sehr stark davon ab, äh wie schnell jetzt wo geöffnet äh wird, weil es ist halt dieser Wettlauf äh zwischen eben.
Dem Impfen und dem Sommer auf der einen Seite und dem,
lockern äh auf der anderen Seite und die zuppeln halt beide am R-Wert rum. Und wir haben im Moment grade nur,
zehn Prozent Abstand nach oben, also null Komma eins und der kann halt auch äh wieder rasch verloren,
aufpassen. Aber und im Moment scheint aber die Politik äh,
noch entschlossen zu sein, jetzt äh also ich sehe keine Lockerungsorgien im Moment, aber das kann alt wieder ganz schnell kommen.
Oh, oh ja, ist das grad ganz schnell kommen. Oh Mann, ey.
Und dann und dann kann's sein, dass wir doch nochmal ein Bamb kriegen, also wenn wir, wenn wir mit Lockerungsorien anfangen, dass wir das dann äh sagen nochmal in den Zahlen äh sehen werden.
Aber zumindest was man sagen kann das tatsächlich
es durch Impfen der Älteren zumindest dafür sorgen äh wird, dass äh dass äh unser Gesundheitssystem, also es ist eine Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems äh jetzt
äh abgewendet ist. Das kann man zumindest sagen, dass wird,
sehr wahrscheinlich nicht passieren und da hätten wir jetzt dann auch genug Zeit nochmal zu reagieren, falls.
Die Zahlen unerwartet äh doch nochmal sehr stark in die Höhe schießen, aber in Ländern, wo.
Geimpft wurde, haben wir den Effekt nirgendwo gesehen bisher, insofern äh ist das eher unwahrscheinlich, also in Israel oder in Großbritannien gab's da auch nichts mehr, insofern,
kann man nur hoffen äh oder äh sag mal mit begründet erwarten.
Ich ich möchte noch anfügen, dass dass die, die jetzt äh das gehört haben, was du gesagt hast und die im Gesundheitssystem arbeiten und sich jetzt denken so, wie das Gesundheitssystem ist nicht überlastet,
Die sind schon vorher vor dieser Pandemie, waren die alle schon total überlastet, ja? Wir reden sozusagen über eine, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennen soll, Überlastung äh äh im Zustand.
Ja genau, also der Zusammenbruch wurde verhindert, aber die Überlastung, die ist real.
Ähm also ich meine, es ist immer eine eine Definitions äh Frage und äh ich meine ja, der Schaden ist den, den,
diese Pandemie angerichtet hat, auch bei Mitarbeitern im äh Gesundheitswesen äh dass äh wird uns,
auch noch äh eine Weile begleiten. Also ich ähm habe jetzt zwar die genauen Zahlen nicht, wie viele Leute
gekündigt haben, aber ich hab zumindest Meldungen darüber gehört, dass irgendwie es tausende von auch abging gegeben hat, von Leuten, aber
ob das jetzt mehr ist als normal oder weniger äh.
Wird sich erst dort zeigen, da gibt's auf jeden Fall auch saisonale Bewegungen und so. Das äh kann man jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht erörtern. Lass uns jetzt Schluss machen hier an dieser Stelle.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören in dieser Woche. Vielen Dank fürs äh Zuhören. Vielleicht auch in der nächsten Woche, da gibt's das nächste Corona-Wikli. Noch habt ihr ja gehört, noch bleiben wir äh dran. Ich würde mal sagen, so mindestens bis zum,
Sommer. Wenn wir hier noch äh Updates liefern, solange es noch interessant bleibt und danach schauen wir mal, ne.
Und jetzt können wir erstmal nur ein schönes Wochenende äh wünschen oder was jetzt äh nach dem Hören dieser Sendung für euch äh dran ist und äh wenn ihr Lust habt, schaut ihr am Dienstag nochmal im Clubhaus mit rein und nehmt an unseren Diskussionen dort.
Teil des immer ganz interessant und äh wenn nicht, dann hören wir uns in der Woche nochmal und bis dahin sage ich.